hmm
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in as that is the most
important metric that YouTube uses to
push out these streams
um a couple announcements before we
start the show the first guys I need you
to sign up for our Google form we're
going to be doing meetups in the United
States and in England I'm probably going
back to the US for maybe a week or two
weeks maybe in July end of July so if
you guys want to be a part of our
meetups we're going to do those this
summer also guys we have two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily make sure you go subscribe to both
and if you want to be a part of the chat
today how many likes do we need to open
up the chat King
a thousand like a thousand likes today
and we will open up the chat also guys
make sure you go subscribe to wife
school I have a new episode of me
needing bread yeah I know how to knead
bread is that
a question here in this room who knows
how to knead bread no John okay no they
told me someone told me the other day I
think it was Auntie someone told me
everyone in England knows how to need
bread they learned that in school he
told you that I don't know
there's no way
I don't know what he told you yeah I
think it was Auntie or something I
didn't even know you need bread
yeah this is what I was like there's no
way the people I've met here and I want
to need Brad
when I eat bread I just go to the store
eating bread
there's okay so subscribe to wife school
and then we have four membership tiers
remember the fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month you
know some people myself I call myself
the queen of YouTube and I really think
that I am because I'm very good at
YouTube so you know if you want send
them for a fourth tier to get a
one-on-one consultation with me once a
month you know we'll go through your
project progress your analytics all that
stuff also my Instagram just pearly
things one go follow it they're always
Banning me on these apps it's my second
Instagram
and now I'm on my my fifth tick tock
it's like what do I say that's so crazy
um but go follow it they gave me my
first username back which is exciting
just pearly things
um also guys just a little bit of a
heads up we are going to be starting um
a new cultural commentary podcast
um that I'm doing we're still doing
shows but I'm going to add that probably
in July
also
um make sure you oh what are we saving
for and above how many super chats are
we going to read King
okay I'm so nice I let him pick 20. over
20 super chats will read today so you
have a question for the panel or a
comment you want to make
um so we're going to do name age
relationship status and a fun fact but
I'm gonna first say guys
um initially we are going to react to
the Andrew Tate interview that he
dropped last week but we just found out
that he's live streaming on Rumble so we
might try to react to that if it works
we'll see
um but let's start so name age
relationship status and fun fact okay
um so my name is honey I'm 26.
um
fun fact about B is that I'm I also make
YouTube content uh my name on YouTube is
keeping up with honey and what was the
other thing I'm sorry name age
relationship status fun fact yeah
relationship um single sadly enough
maybe maybe you won't be after the show
they could message you you know
hopefully
go ahead all right so my name's s I'm 23
years old I'm currently in a
relationship and a fun fact about me is
that although I grew up as an artist I
am at heart a director so I like to
shoot music videos
um as a hobby whilst I'm let's promise
oh yeah that was awesome but yeah uh hi
my name is kit I am 29
um I'm currently seeing someone and fun
fact about me is uh I think I said this
before but I won best actor award for
one of my films recently awesome come on
uh my name is MLD YouTuber the notorious
MLD that's me Mr Endor Mr endure himself
we endure everything I'm enduring over
here you endured the heat right I'm
enduring no air conditioning in London
no I'm still I'm still figuring this out
you ignored the boat tour yeah yeah you
endured a three-hour reaction yep it's
just enduring
um relationship status is uh recently
single single now for about two months
um fun fact about me I actually work for
this man uh Mr Troy Francis I'm his
executive assistant so he's the real
boss over here
good to see you MLD
you're up I am Troy I am 47 and I am
sadly single this hasn't worked out
even though I'm a dating coach and
people flame that but then the thing is
if you have if you're in a relationship
and you're a dating coach then people
criticize that because then they'll say
well you can never win with you yeah
you're banned from dating coaching yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah by the way you're
bad um fun fact about me is I have just
been reunited with my good friend MLB
and we haven't seen each other for what
uh oh man is it 10 months or something
last time we saw each other was in
October in Colombia yes yes so well we
were being good Christian men absolutely
absolutely
what church did you guys go to
the Church of the red
pills
and Reverend Myron Gaines
do you swear
um okay guys so again we're gonna try
we're gonna look at Tate's emergency
meeting who here is familiar with Tate
Andrew Tate oh I'm from here all right
buddy does anybody do you all right does
anybody not like him anyone got a strong
anti-tate
no basically like I have like a
um in between views on him so sometimes
I understand him like when he talks
about you know dating in an
old-fashioned way because I think that
is something that we should be doing
um but then when he says stuff like oh
you know women are better when they are
younger 18 19 go pursue them there was
one I can't remember word for word he
said he'd rather date a 19 year old than
a 26 year old yeah and then he was
basically devaluing the older women yeah
so I was like I don't like that because
that falls under my category and that
tricked me that that trigger the nerve
okay but then other than that
do you think that men or women are
allowed to like men that are rich
um a woman can like whoever she wants to
like but yeah but then why can't the men
like whoever they want to like they can
yeah you know I think everyone can have
a preference and they can like whoever
they want to like as long as you're not
disrespecting other people and different
categories okay I'm 26 you know oh I'm
26 too yeah but but it's like I think I
understand where he's coming from even
being 26 because it's like there's less
experience like there's a guy want a
girl with a ton of experience
do you why would you want someone who's
so naive because I remember when I was
18 19 I thought I knew so much but I
didn't know nothing because when you're
not naive it's like you're always
arguing with him like oh I know what
you're doing you know like yeah yeah
yeah she's laughing right because it's
like they don't want a girl that's like
always like because of Trauma from
previous relationships always bringing
up those problems yeah you know because
like imagine like you know at 26 like I
might if he had I'm trying to think of
something I can't just be positive I'm
not trying to think I'm trying to think
of something off but you can could think
of something maybe an ex did that was
like sneaky yeah right right yeah yeah
and if someone in the future does that
same thing you might think like I don't
know maybe bring a phone to the bathroom
whatever it is the guys would rather
just have a girl that's like oh why
don't he's just bringing this phone or
whatever that's you know but you know
what yeah he should date someone who's
intelligent at the same time because
like for me it doesn't mean she's dumb I
know but you go with us in our bucket
yeah if we get like okay say now I have
a relationship tomorrow blah blah blah
not that I can't get one I'm just picky
by the way don't get twisted I'm not
desperate but
it sounds pretty desperate to me
even every woman right every woman's
picky yes exactly why does every girl
say that like I I could be having a
boyfriend right now like what why
because there I can't there's so many
Sims out there that will do anything
yeah one of the thing is if you're
single it means the men that you want
don't want you
it does it for everybody
if a guy's single it's the same thing
the women that he wants doesn't want him
you know how you said um if a guy is
single that it could be um or he doesn't
want a relationship yeah yeah it's
debatable but yeah like for example the
guy that I wanted to marry before
um he met my standards I clearly met his
we was talking about these things but
however there were certain qualities
that didn't like certain conversations
that we had like for example
he would ask me in the future if you
have like 10 kids would you um we have
10 kids together we've been married for
10 years would you let me have a second
wife in islamically that's obviously
allowed
um but some women are okay with it and
some women are not so I told him I'm not
gonna lie I'm not okay with that you're
basically rinsing me out and then after
that you're gonna go for someone younger
and then I'm just the first wife
whatever I'm not really with that
um and then from there we kind of
started getting put off by each other so
then that that fizzled out so it had
nothing to do with him wanting me or him
not wanting me well he wasn't the guy
you wanted because you wanted a
different thing yeah but the point is
like the guy that matched all those
requirements like the guy the same guy
that matches those requirements and
wants monogamy like does either like he
doesn't want you if you're not with him
are you a Muslim woman
you're Muslim yes but I'm not religious
I'm still okay religious but I am going
to become religious one day so I do have
Kerry some of those could it be that the
high value could it be the kind of high
value dude that you want to meet though
he might require that you share him you
know it could be that you meet another
high value guy who meets or who takes
all your boxes and he's going to say
something similar I always say that
though but I always say that I think
it's terrible advice that guys give
other guys like forcing women to accept
the fact that other women are going to
be in the picture because women with
self-respect they're not going to accept
that they're not gonna be like yeah just
bring some other woman into the picture
like normal women are not going to
tolerate I think a lot of women will
tolerate cheating is cheating there's
one thing not another main challenge if
you can keep it
cheating is God's work because I think
so many women cheating cheating is for
women it's men do it for women
interesting women in a way
excited chicks all the time because
because we start out in situationships
right right so so that like what is that
so I think it depends on the site
what do you mean like for example let's
say when a westernized society you're on
Eastern site like don't you think that
the way that someone would accept their
side chick or not would vary yeah it's
gonna depend where you're at I think
like if you look at the Western thing I
think yeah I think if you like look at
somewhere like Dubai or towards the
Eastern side of things like I think
they'd look at things more from uh
what's my future gonna look like
financially how my family how's things
going to be set up but then if you come
further to like the Western I say is I
think it's more emotion based and it's
an attention that's actually very funny
a lot of Japanese wives like when they
kind of like you know are kind of
checked out they just want to be a mom
like japanese-wise notoriously known for
after they have children they basically
stop having sex with a husband and some
of them are just like just go get a
girlfriend
because they just want to take care of
the kids like when when a woman has
children
nothing is in more important than her
children that's true I also I also agree
with you there but wouldn't you also
um back to the the possibility that it
could be the way that they're also
raised in their households so for
example let's say that let's say that
they're raising their households with
the mindsets that yo you're going to
have a husband one day so be like this
be like that be like that and when
you've got all those predetermined Like
rules beforehand don't you think that
kind of affects the Romantic Romanticism
of a relationship but it doesn't depend
on Life Stage as well because he's
describing you know women who are a
little bit older maybe and they've
already been married they've had their
kids so now they're their priorities
so now their priorities have shifted a
bit you know you know how you even said
like oh could it also be a factor
because of age and so forth like I do
believe that some factors can combine
with other factors yeah of course yeah
yeah for sure but I think in the west
you get that as well because you might
get young girl who's like happy to party
and she's happy to you know be a side
chick and everything else but she's not
necessarily going to be so comfortable
to accept that when she you know when
she gets married to a dude and and I'll
say this the girls that I know who have
agreed to be side chicks like they're a
little off like they're just like they
they have like they have a
dick stained pass
it might be you know party people they
might be addicted to drugs or casually
smoke weed and think like you know
they're just not they're not 100 there
but my original statement is agreeing
with the young lady over there I'm sorry
honey honey yeah honey was I was
agreeing with honey and I talked to and
actually yesterday when I was doing the
duo stream with pearl and I talked to
Pearl about the same thing I definitely
agree I think it's I think it's terrible
advice that these
content creators are telling regular
guys like get out there and force your
girl to take to accept you and another
woman because the average woman with
like a fraction of self-respect is just
not gonna be okay with that and if she
is she's not gonna love you with the
entirety of her being compared to if she
she knows it it's just you two together
I'm curious and you don't have to answer
this but I'm just curious It's not
talking to me I'll answer anything the
other like content creators in the space
that push like non-monogamy is that what
you found like when you've met their
girlfriends like something has been
awesome no yeah this is not this is not
uh it's just not a dissetting these guys
or any of their women or anything all
I'm saying is from my life experience
and talking to other people who are
really good at understanding female
nature and are dating coaches and Mike
experience as well because I did the
whole thing I I try to openly tell you
know multiple women when I was dating
them at the same time and it was hell
because well okay it was it was
hilarious because you know female
pettiness knows no end yeah uh there was
like this there's like this medicine
cabinet in my penthouse that I was
living in Tokyo right and one girl would
put her stuff in there and another girl
started snooping through it and it was
two Japanese girls and a Chinese girl
and they all started like this silent
Civil War of toothbrushes of
toothbrushes and makeup in this little
medicine cabinet and all it did despite
me getting sex and servitude from all
these women it stressed the [__] out of
me and I was just stressed out from
their [__] fighting at all time they
never got in line and they all all three
of them vented to me every time we got
together on how much they hated the
other girls and eventually I lost all
three of them so may am I a low value
beta male I don't know should I tell you
what I think should I tell you what I
think the mistake in that is I think
it's
it sounded like they were all three of
them had the position of being your main
woman
uh no there was there was a there was a
hierarchy there yeah but what I mean is
you were giving you were giving all
three of them a level of emotional and
time investment right as opposed to
having one main girl right and then
she's like okay she understands that
maybe every now and again you may
exercise a physical option but that
woman isn't going to be leaving her
toothbrush around because that woman
you're not really dating seriously do
you understand what I'm saying yeah I
see what you're saying but it's I I just
don't think it's can I don't think it
works I don't because women
women are so competitive with each other
yeah and they hate each other and they
are so petty one girl when she would
watch
clothes whatever and sometimes this
other girl left her bra or panties in my
washing machine and she would just take
it throw it behind the washing machine
and then the other girl would always
find her underwear she's like somebody's
throwing my underwear down I was like no
it's my cleaning lady I'm so sorry she's
from beautiful um
if you also if you also look at how men
and women also Express themselves though
I say men are a lot more close to the
physical side of things and women are a
lot more close to the emotional
emotional and verbalized I think he
makes a good point I mean there's a
couple of content creators which bring
to mind who are very very they really
push this line I think they really work
out they really push this line of like
no you've got to be you've got to be
upfront you've got to be honest with her
this is how the deal's gonna be right
you may be my main girl but I'm gonna
I'm gonna have sex you know around I
think it's it's extremely difficult to
pull off I would say for the average guy
there may be some guys who can pull it
off and even then how what longevity
that's gonna happen yeah is another
thing I'm a guy I'm a guy that's in you
know in regards to success you know it
was very evident that I'm successful you
know putting it down in the bedroom I
take care of everybody nobody pays for
anything I'm not a [__] Sim I'm not
paying bills for any of these hoes but
like you know like when they're with me
when I'm we're with me dinner's covered
the Ubers are covered everything's
sorted so I don't know am I such a
[__] beta male that they just don't
submit to my alpheness no but I don't
think that's the case I just I and then
from the women I've talked to and I
asked Pearl yesterday and now
um sorry honey honey again just
reiterated the same fact that she did
not want to be in a situation when a man
was juggling multiple women however
however however if I now push I'm 40
yeah yeah single God forbid with no kids
God forbid again then
um my value has decreased massively so
I'm also aware of that so then from yeah
degree so then what I would do is
because I'm desperate at that point
I would be a second wife but only
islamically only because I feel like
islamically it can work because this
structure so if he has two wives
that seven days in a week
will calculate it to three me three her
then that one odd day 40 you only get
like two
no no you have to be even or else he's
gonna get he's gonna get us in so the
way it works is
this usually men that are more religious
usually take that responsibility because
it's a big responsibility he is
responsible for me and her he has to
treat us equally he can't buy one person
a sweet and not buy the other one a
sweet tomorrow and he has to split his
days equally so that one off day in the
week we are rotating this week so I want
to add on to that so and now that in my
opinion adds to my original statement
because now this is no longer romantic
love this is transactional you're like
all right well here I'll suck your dick
on this day and this day
it all sounds very sort of uh structured
doesn't it actually I actually think
that most love likely is transactional
love to an extent yeah and I think it
almost like should be in a way it should
be yeah okay what do you think it should
be because hear me out women find 80 of
men is ugly yeah eighty percent of men
ugly ugly ugly and yeah so I can agree
with that walking around London well
yeah
you know so it's like women really only
are going to have genuine desire for
like 20 of men maybe 25. well don't you
see that so so it's like what the other
girls what do they got they gotta they
either die alone or you know
who've got this who's got the stat about
India though marriages arranged
marriages in India and how successful
they are all of Hindus all Hinduism
divorce rate
one percent yeah yeah but you don't
think that's more transactional when
it's a range it is no it is
transactional or it's more like well
listen marriage the reason why
westerners suck at marriage namely women
is because they are based they're basing
the backbone of their relationships on
feelings and feelings are a fleeting
thing feelings do not stay it's changing
and it's coming and going and if you're
a person who lives your life based upon
your feelings only you're gonna have an
awful life right where your
relationship's gonna be awful marriage
is not based upon feelings marriage is a
logical commitment for between two
people for better for worse for richer
for poor for sick or first for health am
I wrong here in general questions I got
a question for that as well though the
only reason why is because the only
things I'm factoring here I'm also
factoring the biological side of things
as well yeah and it's like to some
degree yeah it's very easy for like and
this isn't in defense it's just like my
opinion in it it's very easy for like us
Mania to be like yo boom a female should
be logical like say let's say I'm
arguing my girlfriend I could be I could
be thinking yo she really should be
thinking this but I really do also
believe that on the flip side of things
I don't understand that chemistry at all
so it's like it's like it's that that
that battle to find that balance of you
should be logical here to some degree
but you're also battling this like how
do you do that because early early when
you're making a point and you were
saying that um that or was it you that
making a point that oh some females you
know they want a bit more attention and
then you made a point earlier saying
that oh as long as it's equal but did
you see the energy she had which said
but if he misses that one day
he misses that one day that's a sin yeah
yeah yeah so so all so already what
because I like to like listen to
everyone and speak after me like from
analyzing that she proved a point she
proved that to some degree her emotion
will come into it yeah and if he does
slip up from the statistical
transactional side of things things can
go left and then the issue is when
things go left how will women react to
it going left well they can go left
definitely but I think what we were
saying about the the Hindu statistic is
that uh when it's structured and when
it's based on something Beyond just
emotion where there's a bigger a wider
structure to it yeah I mean it's it's
more likely to last isn't it look what
happens when women follow their feelings
yeah it's a freaking idiots
100 years ago 95 of people were married
if 95 of people are married now women
have more
power than ever to pick their partner we
have dating apps but we have Instagram
we have more freedom than we've ever had
and less influence from our family
because we're getting married at 31. so
the more freedom the Hat we have the
more divorced our country is
I guess what I'm saying I think the
difference is with marriage especially
with an arranged marriage right it's
about Duty and I think about Duty right
even when you love someone there were
going to be things in order for it to be
successful there are going to be things
that you are going to have to do that
you don't want to do right yes all these
guys are you know your content creators
even Poe right there are plenty of
things about being a content creator
yeah we love creating the content yeah
but there are plenty of things that you
have to do that we if we could choose we
wouldn't have to do we want to buy all
the expensive [__] we don't have to
making thumbnails making thumbnails
we don't have to learn to do that right
but we choose to do those things because
it's about serving the bigger picture
yeah so I think in marriage right when
you only function in from your feelings
you only make decisions from your
feelings it means there are going to be
days where you should be choosing to do
something because it's your duty to even
when you don't want to but for the
marriage yeah but that's the problem but
but probably societally societally the
big problem now is of course there's not
there's not really those constraints
there so yeah and that that's the
fundamental issue what was mentioned
earlier when someone I can't remember if
it was one of you guys but someone
mentioned how when in in the Chinese
Chinese or Japanese relationship yeah
when someone reached the age of 40 years
old the woman was like go have sex with
who you feel like now don't go get a
girlfriend go get a girlfriend now this
is the thing though like I do believe
that within a marriage and within a
relationship there are some factors that
I think should be maintained throughout
from begin it starts till when it ends
and I do think attraction maybe not even
sexual attraction but just attraction of
your partner I think that's something
that should be maintained throughout and
it's like I think that if like what's
the my question is for the balance the
balance of logical things that need to
be done and that fun Romanticism that's
still important I think there should be
no balance
yeah yeah okay I mean is that realistic
in the west maybe if we banned women
voting birth control and a lot of other
stuff
yeah that's a whole nother another topic
but but it's like we look at the
outcomes there's no feelings involved 99
success rate the women's feelings get
involved yeah 50 success rate average
age of marriage is eight years they have
like 12 bodies 90 of us are on birth
control one out of three of us has an
STD
has an abortion and John der because
John zucker's getting laid like a rock
star I mean what's that all about yeah
you know I think the issue with today is
that um everyone's feelings are being
directed in a distracting Manner and I
think that's what the issue is it's not
that people have I think it's women's
feelings yeah women I say women's then
because men not even necessarily control
that element of things but in regards to
women I feel like their feelings are
being directed towards oh wait cardi B
just got bought a Birkin bag from offset
I want my my feelings are telling me I
now want it so now that's the definition
of what love is to me I was I was
listening I was listening to a song from
the 90s and it was like uh Trisha
Yearwood song and in the song it talks
about how the guy gave her his high
school ring as a wedding ring until he
could afford a real one what what
percent of women would accept his high
school ring as their wedding ring get
married in a courthouse and maybe do a
wedding later
we spend so much time thinking about
what what is life gonna be like
um what is this magical wedding day
gonna be like but they've never thought
What's it gonna be like my day-to-day as
a wife
come on the show where she was literally
telling me how she was gonna have four
kids and then meditate in the Morning
Journal like that was how she's gonna
start her day with four kids no no this
is the delusion I'm like you're
someone's gonna be screaming someone's
gonna be crying no he's gonna be pulling
you out of bed yeah but it's like we
have all this thought about a wedding
and never about being a wife
they did a study too that found out like
the larger your wedding is the more
likely you are to get a divorce yeah
everybody yeah they because so many
people here's the biggest problem with
relationships is so many people worried
about what other people think about your
relationship yeah yes that's a big
problem right now you know and this
attention economy you know that
everybody's like oh you know I need to
be this Flex culture I need this I need
that but if a girl is really down for
you she needs like a couple people at
the wedding her family you know Mom Dad
and have a good time and at the end of
the day she really really really loves
you she'll get married at the courthouse
she'll sign paperwork because she's
understanding the longevity of you two
being together is more important than
showing the world how awesome you are as
a lot to relate to this topic a lot
because obviously I'm a female and I've
kind of had to think about these things
um basically like from my experience
when I was younger like in my early 20s
I'm in my mid-20s now obviously but um I
always refused I had like proposals
before and stuff like obviously us
Muslims about marriage more quicker and
all this stuff because it's like
a lot of us are trying to do a culture
and then religious some are more
religious than others so I was speaking
to different guys about marriage yeah
and
um I was declining quite a few of them
because I they didn't really want to
have a big wedding some it wasn't
because of the finances
um some could have been even like the
attention too much attention all these
people for one night I'm spending all
this money and they're gonna share it
out and then tomorrow everyone goes on
the day but we're here dealing with this
so I do I always used to be like no go
away go away because I want this big
wedding I only have one day to get
married I need to see myself do this and
also my sister had a big wedding as well
so I was like hold on I'm not gonna
sound great no ways if she could do it I
could do it too and then now that I'm in
my mid-20s I feel like I've matured a
lot I'm like that's not even important
because what's important is me and him
and getting God involved and committing
those three things are important you can
always do a celebration later like can
we blame them you know can we blame men
for not wanting to spend a ton of money
on the wedding when the average marriage
is like eight years
exactly but I was so oblivious to the
situation I wasn't thinking from that
side alone because it's like we always
talk about that in the media it's always
talking about the wedding but never
being a wife like what what wives like
and traditional wives are really pushed
in the media exactly I couldn't even
think of one real Homemaker traditional
chick that I've Seen On TV that's like
famous that's true I can't think of
those lyrics that you're talking about
though if that was a real story now that
would be a viral Tick Tock wouldn't it
like oh my god look this broke he tried
to he tried to give me my high school
ring
LeBron James's wife yeah yeah LeBron
James as well and now now name like 10
mainstream hoes
speaking of this topic do you guys
believe in evil eye what do you mean
I believe in it and they couldn't even
in our religion we believe in it
basically you can do it intentionally or
unintentionally for example like you
just see someone that looks great or
they have this nice thing we when we say
that we say mashallah so we don't jinx
it accidentally not intentionally but it
can accidentally be like wow and then we
can actually accidentally Jinx that
person so that's actually their thing so
what happens in these big weddings is
you're getting all these people involved
they're all seeing who you're marrying
what you are able to afford you are
causing a lot of attention and it could
be evil eye as well intentionally or
non-intentionally regardless yeah and
then now you don't have all this burden
people people used to just go courthouse
and it was fine but now and like the
other thing is other women ruin it
because they're like oh well my man got
me this my man got me that exactly a lot
of the times the girl's saying that it's
because something's wrong but when you
say is about that like you know how you
said that it's also about being a wife
here like I'm looking at like my
generation as well like I'm 23 in it and
I'm and like I have friends which are
like much younger than me a lot of them
don't focus on the individualized person
like a lot of them yeah they'll because
let's say that some you can take someone
that wants to be a perfect housewife and
someone that wants to be a perfect house
husband put them together and it still
probably won't work and I think the
reason why is because of the way they
romanticize the idea they'll say okay
cool I I'm I've been trained by my mom
to become a wife so I can be ready for a
husband then she finds out that you've
got a habit that just puts it off and
gives it now she doesn't want to
marriage anymore but let's say that the
moment the the Romanticism came with her
saying but I really like the way he
smiles I really like the way he is the
really I really like the way he thinks
that let's say that she grew the idea of
building towards marriage alongside with
his personality involved as well that's
when I believe that she'd know what type
of end product she's going to get with
is it to do with I think I think you
look more at the families and their
values more than personality I think
women get wooed by personality come on
you know you know that guy that's a
sweet talker
and those girls those girls keep on
getting finessed yeah and finesse look
at her not in her head yeah look and I'm
a guy that lives in Tokyo talking about
this and there's a girl in the UK
agreeing with me but equally they get
finesse again and again most don't mind
manipulators no no no she's not meeting
manipulator after manipulator
manipulator she's an idiot
equally I think so these Master
manipulators are not out there
equally I think some women can can be I
mean I dated a woman some years ago and
she was in her later 20s English girl
right and I just felt like and she was
really pushing things towards towards
marriage you know she really wanted
marriage she really wanted commitment
and quite quickly as well and I just
felt right my sense of it my Spidey
senses were tingling I felt that I was
sort of irrelevant really it could have
been me but equally it could have been
some other dude you know she really
wanted that's the point yeah yeah
and I'm sure she I don't agree of course
she like I'm sure she you know she liked
me to some degree whatever but but
equally it was sort of like she wanted
the Instagram pictures she wanted the
you know the idea of a boyfriend exactly
you can see like that's the only element
you see that's the only element I'm
trying to avoid with yes the ideology of
your marriage fair play but I'd also
want her to grow with me as a person
whilst liking what I can provide as a
man because I'm not saying oh you should
just let me and that should
overcompensate with me being lazy I do
think that all men should be working I
do think that well if if ever in my
opinion I think we sell guys a dream
that guy that girls like them for them
yeah but this is my balance though I'm
saying that balance it I'm not saying
now don't work I'm saying be the best
version of yourself right so so forth
but also make sure that the person
you're selecting also likes you can I
ask you so wait what did you mean by
that I just mean like I I think we tell
guys just be yourself and like women
will come and I just think that that's
not particularly true so do you think it
is really transactional you don't think
like a girl look at a guy I think
nowadays it is I think maybe it used to
be different you know we speak more at
families and values but now it's like
girls will just ask how much money you
make like girl I mean what if someone's
naturally ambitious though like let's
say that they've got an absolute desire
to get back on their phone and hustle
because that's their routine before they
even was in a relationship and let's say
that's part of my natural personality
another girl could look at that and be
like oh this guy never has time for me
yeah
yeah yeah it's ironic though it's ironic
because women want the the end fruits of
the success but actually they can some I
mean sometimes and like maybe you've had
different experiences but sometimes um
they can also sort of impede you know if
you're like right I want to spend 12
hours hustling she's like no no I want
to go yeah
yeah every like yeah there's a
difference between like women who want a
high value guy and women who know how to
deal it will support a high value yeah
who know how to deal with the reality
the day in day out of a high Valley guy
like I was I was dating a girl and one
time she was like you know we need more
quality time together I'm like what do
you mean you're over here all the time
you know I was like you're like the fact
that I even let you into my life is
equality in itself yeah but they want
you to really give them an extreme
amount of attention but you know you
have to convey to these women like look
that's not how this is gonna work you
you you can go find another guy maybe
he's good at guitar he could play you a
song yeah but you guys can fly economy
but if you want a high value dude and
you want a guy that is dedicated to
something bigger than the both of you
put together you're gonna have to make
some compromises yes but you'll be
compromising in business class so like
you gotta choose your you know choose
your fortune that you want to go for is
the love and the Romanticism and all
this [__] that is eventually going to
fade away or something that's going to
last a little bit longer but I think
right now ultimately because in the
Western World right because I live in in
Asia and so in the western world they're
just constantly lying to women saying
you can have it all yeah you can be a
CEO and a mother and have the perfect
guy and never have relationship problems
and you'll be debt free and you're not
going to be fat and everybody's gonna
love you and you're never gonna stop
losing attention from Men You're Gonna
Be beautiful into your 50s like JLo and
that's just not the reality that's
actually partially what got me into this
content was because I would hear women
talk about it they wanted to date a high
value guy and I'm just like thinking and
I think of like my dad working growing
up and I'm like you think you're gonna
have date nights every Friday with a guy
that's working yeah
I think there's a lot good luck like I
hope I hope it works out for you but
it's just not realistic I have a
question for you based on what you were
saying earlier do you um do you do you
believe that you can learn to love
someone do you believe you can learn to
love someone I think you grow on you I
think you learn to love every person you
ever love because every person you love
you never love because you're the same
because you know how you like you were
saying about oh a girl kind of you know
meets with a guy who could be a perfect
husband but then he does something
that's her ache and she's like nah I'm
out yeah yeah so it might I would say to
that I'm like she is not wifey material
oh yeah she's not the perfect wife
because if if something that he's doing
that isn't a Jeopardy to the
relationship like he's got a weird snore
or something yeah yeah right and she's
like I can see he's a great quality guy
he's committed and I could have a good
future with him but because of this one
thing I'm gonna jeopardize all of that I
would say she's not serious about the
marriage what I would say to that is
that in general yeah every relationship
you get to you're gonna find things that
you love about your partner the things
that you dislike about your partner like
very naturally in it and what what I'd
also say to that is that like
if if let's say that okay cool we can
all in our own heads pick what we deem
as important and not important so the
way she could dream you don't need to be
on your Instagram dming people so much
you could be like no this is my bread
and it's really about how you like
balance what's wrong with each other
because I really think that a lot of
these red flags people act like they
can't see red flags they are like like
they'll see all no matter no they're
just blinded by men will admit there's
red flags women are the ones they're
like oh he changed as soon as we started
dating yeah but it's like okay but but
the question you have to ask is did your
parents like him
but no
you said earlier on um about women
rushing to get married because they like
the idea of marriage and wedding but
they're not thinking the actual concept
of becoming a wife yeah the
responsibilities of it I've actually
have I've actually had a friend that
literally got married because of the
idea of marriage and kids quickly and
then within being a wife process the man
was like asking her to cook every night
because she's at home
taking care of the baby he's working so
of course you should be like at least
packing the house cooking and cleaning
she didn't want to do it she didn't want
to do it he was like what he went to his
mom's house complained at his mom's food
came back and she's on the phone to me
saying oh he's expecting dinner tonight
and I'm telling her girl I'm not married
and I'm single even I know that you have
to be in that kitchen I'm just thinking
like doesn't doesn't she have to eat so
she used to cook for herself anyway yeah
you know what she said she said
I'd rather eat something quick or maybe
a takeaway that I can't be asked and I
told her like I'm not gonna lie this is
your responsibility your man is
completely writing this if you don't if
you want if you care for your marriage
and you want to stay married you better
be in that kitchen and make sure that
food is ready before eight o'clock it
shows a modern mindset because she cares
about what she wants not what's best for
the family it's not good for a family to
have these quick meals like it's good
for the family to have like sit down sit
down yeah but that's the thing that
lowers like depression anxiety feelings
of worthless that it's a gigantic
important thing for a family to sit down
and have regular meals I was just happy
that she called me to ask me I said are
you cool the right person go in that
kitchen uh we were gonna start the video
though
um so guys we're gonna watch and now we
got a little off topic but okay so
Andrew Tate's okay everyone else Andrew
Tate fans yes 10 out of 10. he's not a
fan you're kind of what 50 50. no I post
that I'm I'm on board 75
um I completely agree with
responsibility but I think some things
he says is is about preference that I
would be like Ah that's maybe not my
preference in how I would operate in
that way but I think fundamentally yeah
I do agree with what he says okay all
right let's pull pull the footage pull
the footage King
uh what do you I wonder what he's gonna
talk about because he's this is huge I
think he has 385
000 years right now that's freaking
crazy you know and this is his first
emergency meeting since being
incarcerated in the Romanian uh prisons
and then being on house arrest as well
what a contrast between the two I know
that's a nice suit there Tristan has
he's got it
I can't hear
do you allow cigar smoking in the just
pearly things
no I do not no I do not
test I said I would never give up on the
people I said I would never give up on
our fans I said I will not just take my
hundreds of millions but I got it I got
into the hills I said I would never quit
but you never actually answered the
question you're rich you're strong
you've got a family you've got me you
could disappear from this we could
delete all of our internet profiles
tomorrow we could vanish from the
internet and we would live amazing lives
incomparable to most Lives Many Men
would ever live
so I guess the question that everyone's
looking for an answer to
is what are you going to do
I know the answer it's gonna endure
you know what makes me sad
if I thought crying was constructive I
would cry but it's not who I am I don't
think it's constructive I don't think
it's the correct thing to do but I'm not
sad for myself I'm prepared to suffer
I've built a life in which I must suffer
but I am sad for the people around me
and I'm
because I know this Matrix attack has
just begun and I'm sad because I know
they're going to try and push this to
the end they're going to genuinely try
and put us in jail for no reason I'm sad
that other countries out there which I
love which I grew up in which I'm
patriotic to which I have the passport
to are out to get me and hurt me for no
reason other than the fact I'm trying to
do good I'm sad for the people around me
who I love who rely on me not just on me
for money but also for my presence as a
whole I'm sad they want to take me away
from my [__] children I'm sad they
want to leave me to Raw in a hole for
what what for and I'm sad that they want
to turn me into a coward and I either
have to go and live and sit in my room
with all my money and try and distract
myself with Hedonism and a bunch of
women or go
coward or I have to sit and be a sad
hero and there's no in between not about
that's what really upsets me I'm left
with those two choices I'm either a hero
who must suffer endlessly this
is just the beginning none of this is
going away you think this is going away
so this is the beginning of all of it
it's never gonna [__] end they're
gonna continue to attack me for the end
of time no matter what they're gonna
keep doing it to me and I'm sad that my
children are gonna wake up every day
wondering if dad's in jail for no reason
or if Dad's been assassinated yet you
think they're gonna allow me to continue
to spread good when they're truly evil
in their hearts I'll put a bullet in my
head I'm sad knowing that I can have the
best life on earth and the only thing I
have to do is be a coward to live it but
I don't want to [__] wake up every
day looking over my shoulder worried
about being killed the alternative to it
is to wake up every day and feel like a
[__] [__]
okay wait hold on it's pretty pretty
intense it's intense you're jumping as
well I don't know yeah I think it it's
glitching but anyways the rumble servers
might not be able to handle that because
there's so many people watching this
file yeah well we can we can go to the
live but what'd you guys I was gonna
pause it in a second anyway I I think I
don't think he has to
oh they doesn't have to worry
I think the anyone who's watched him
especially interviews you talk about the
Matrix and the people in power that at B
right the last thing they want to do the
last thing they want to do is make him a
martyr because if anything happened to
Andrew Tate
if anything happened right that is going
to elevate the movement globally because
it will literally confirm everything he
has ever said about this whole Matrix
thing so I don't think is he gonna
soften sense them coming for him of
course they're going to try and continue
to but I think in terms of his life and
stuff I don't that would be the worst
case for the enemy if you know so I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you the optimism
perspective of things right so I I think
that they're just so desperate right now
because I honestly I I just think Donald
Trump has a couple steps ahead of Andrew
Tate right because I mean I mean there
actually may well date is has done
prison time but they haven't hit it with
a crime yet but they're trying the same
[__] that they're doing to Trump right
now which is completely unjust because
if you look at people like Dick Cheney
hey look at people like Biden where they
found a bunch of classified documents in
his house already and if you if you've
seen anything that Hunter Biden has done
on that laptop I mean the fact that
these people run me free but then Trump
came into office and you know his
biggest sin was
he didn't start a new war
he was the first president
who did not start a new war
in American history going back to I
don't even know when I think I literally
think every president after Eisenhower
because there was Korean war after that
and then there was Vietnam and then you
had you know Operation Freedom and then
enduring Freedom all the stuff in the
Middle East and Trump on 2016 or the
thing was I think it was like 2016 yeah
he was uh at one of the debates and he
said that like the whole reason that we
were in the Middle East was total
[__] there were no weapons of mass
destruction so he went against the
Matrix and now Andrew was smart enough
to know
that there are literally hundreds of
millions of disenfranchised young men
who were tired of being [__] on by
mainstream Media news government video
games social media everywhere you turn
they're [__] on these young men
telling them you're a bad person you're
a Grapist you're a misogynist you're
this you know you're part of the
patriarchy and all these guys are just
like young impressionable young men who
are just sitting at home and like what
did I do like a lot of these young guys
this is an American eccentric thing but
a lot of young white guys are feeling
bad for being white they're just like
yeah you're bad because you're white
like dude my name is Spencer and I'm
like 17 and I like Call of Duty and it's
like all of the the like the Matrix and
Matrix in the media what are they
pushing and that's the crazy thing like
I just got off a stream where they were
literally pushing that women should
sleep around as opposed to being virgins
yeah yeah like they it's like what are
you pushing you're pushing for
promiscuity which isn't good for women
yeah and it's not and it's not good
sorry I had gone I was just gonna say
the guy running that stream is a fat
loser who's getting divorced by his wife
what context does that guy really have
well I mean I'm not even I don't even
care about that I'm just saying it's
like what what values what mission do
these people push and it's like when
somebody genuinely has a good message
like Tate they will do everything in
their power to destroy him yep
The Genius of of type though the genius
of Andrew type though and Tristan said
recently that Andrew tight has altered
forever the
the term influencer the meaning of the
term influencer because Andrew Tate is
somebody who genuinely influences the
youth you know genuinely influences
young men and indeed some women in a way
that nobody has ever done before I mean
this isn't just about doing pranks on
YouTube videos or making stupid tick
tocks or something this is somebody who
has who has genuine actual influence and
when you look at something like the bit
that we just saw which was very intense
like like John was saying
um
nobody
has managed to articulate what he's what
he's getting across in the way that he
has all right and and the genius of him
himself as a marketer but also as
somebody who is is highlighting exactly
what John's talking about you know that
Schism between uh what the the perceived
Elites one versus what's what people on
the ground want nobody else other than
him has managed to articulate that in
such a powerful and such a colorful and
such a a resonant way and I think that
that it's just a master class in being a
rhetorician right it's just a master
class in communication and the ability
to influence a mass audience at scale so
it's really quite incredible what we're
seeing yeah but I feel like in terms of
um getting of him or
to harm him I feel like they would love
to but
too but
potentially when this dies down they
might come back to bite him I don't know
the only way they should die down is if
he was let go
that's not like because if he goes to
jail there's going to be more yeah
everything like it's going to be
consistent is it is is going to be
consistent I meant as in like there will
they would maybe let time go by and then
strike again so then it looks like it's
not them and they make it look like a
suicidal or something no but he said
live on stream um uh on pbd's podcast he
was like I'm saying this for the record
right now I would never ever commit
suicide especially being a Muslim now as
well it was like so if anything ever
comes up that if I'm detained and
something happened just know that is
what it is that wasn't me yeah he was
like on uh pbd stream though wasn't he
that um even if he gets exonerated in in
terms of this specific trial yeah he's
always going to be looking over his
shoulder that threat is always going to
be there you know yeah yeah I want it
someone in the chat says he does have
influenced my little brother has seen
his shorts of him working out my brother
was inspired to get into fitness and
he's 11. so these people actually think
he's got like a negative effect on the
world
I did I did um interviews at carnival
like last year and I just would ask
girls like oh what do you think of Tate
and I was like oh what do you think of
Andrew I hate that
hate that but even that in itself though
don't you believe that that's just a
program into some degree because I also
think Hate's closer to love I think you
can flip it a lot quicker yeah the fine
lines you sound like Patrice O'Neal yeah
really I don't know
okay well I think I actually saw one of
those with them one of the videos that
you've done in public where you were
going around asking people what do you
think of ngt yeah because those were
going around in general when it was like
he was like blown up in it yeah and what
I was finding that like the most common
thing you say to them is why do you hate
him
I don't know
same girls that can't name three
countries on fresh and thin
but that's what I'm saying I think it's
just a program I think that in general
let's say that annotate isn't the face
of it and this let's say that we've got
something else called I don't know let's
say an avocado if the government if if
like the system pushes it in front of
people's faces to tell you you need to
hate this you need to hate this you need
to hate this this discussion is no
longer necessarily about annotating
necessarily then it's about how they can
control who you hate and I think that's
a bigger issue than hating Andrews 8
because the fact that is let's say that
you've done that podcast now you're not
a stream and all the female said I don't
like him because he said this specific
sentence to me and it made me feel like
this and it reminded me of this trauma
thing that happened to me in the past
let's say that those were their
responses I'd be like you know what I
like him you don't like him that's fair
in it but their responses were I don't
know is that not scary monkey does
monkey do monkey monkey monkey
yes so many times it's women are more
susceptible to propaganda much more than
men they're much more easily influenced
but I do I do think we should play more
of the
Rumble servers have caught up yeah let's
see
oh tell the truth I'm left with two [__]
choices why for following God for
telling people to be a good person it's
disgusting what's happening to me I'm
sad not for me I'm sad for everybody
around me it's disgusting
I don't know
they'll have to kill me first if there
was a if there was a choice there's not
even a choice in my mind I I can't live
at the coward I can't live with the
person I can't sell my sanity I can't
throw my brain away and sit out here and
just [__] lie to everybody and tell
them to be slaves like everybody else
can I can't put on a Pokemon costume and
be a [__] clown I can't be that
person I have to be the person who tells
the truth that tries to improve the
world I've always done my best to help
people we donate so much money to
charity name another person name one
detractor or one person who hates us
who's donating a penny to anybody who's
feeding anybody none of them are nobody
cares it's just you and me were the only
people out here doing it all the people
who are after us now for money and these
fake charges and this fake garbage
they're always trying to steal all our
wealth what will they do with it will
they donate it to charity will they help
anybody of course
well I guess this is a good time to
pause anyway
I was gonna say like I think a big
reason why um
why women have so much distaste for him
right is because
and I say this as a dating Mentor who
primary coaches women there is a
significant amount of packaging in how
you say something like
and you take communicates very much how
men do very directly yeah we don't care
how you say it to us we want to know the
point right we want solutions to the
problem exactly yes when it comes to
women it is very important in the
delivery and if they've if the delivery
uh metric isn't met to the point that
they can digest it it doesn't matter
what if you're saying that you know what
goes up must come down they're gonna
hate you for saying that do you see what
I'm saying is this how you make them
feel well yeah I accept that as well but
I also I also don't wanna underestimate
how intelligent women also are as well
everyone
because like the reason why I'm saying
that is because I do believe that you
know how you say that it's important we
break things down so that they can
understand it I believe that sometimes
they know
I don't think he's he's I forgive me I
don't think he was saying that they
weren't intelligent yeah
always have a visceral reaction to the
way that men speak to each other when
it's in a super masculine yeah yeah I
have a best friend in situations and I'm
like it's there's a reason it's called
locker room talk yeah there's a reason
that when that clip of trump went viral
saying by the post like I'll freaked out
yeah when the guys all know they've
heard their friends say something like
this but you know because you know why
the reality is this it's sad to say but
women can't handle the truth that's why
they watch Oprah who sits there and lies
to their [__] lies they're protected
you know that's why they watch Dr Phil
that's why they watch The View and look
we talked about this the other day
remember when Elva was like well you
know you got to change the message like
listen to Nova calm down the reality is
this Andrews Tate wasn't talking to
women yeah his message wasn't catered to
women Andrew Tate's expertise is how to
be an above average excellent man so
he's speaking man-to-man look how mean
uh kit here when I I just we were just
agreeing right now he was saying like
men only care about getting the solution
to the problem we haven't met each other
but that's just how simple and easy men
are doesn't matter if you're black
doesn't matter if you're white if you
want a [__] problem solved you want
it solved as soon as possible as
efficiently as possible and I don't care
if you call me a [__] whatever yeah we
just want the solution conveyed to us as
soon as possible women want to talk
about how the problem makes us feel yeah
locker room taught for women like
they're actually they're actually more
gross than men like yeah they can go in
and they'll be like yo yeah his dick was
this veiny wow
talk it's actually as bad as men but
they're actually just are very good
things what are the things that's
happening with tight is is that yeah
you're right he was speaking to men and
I mean we've we we're old enough now to
remember when he was Far smaller than he
is now yeah I mean on on he was always
big he was always sort of guy who drew a
lot of attention but nothing like what
he is now and it was always basically he
was you know doing kind of he was in
chat rooms with us exactly exactly
exactly he was talking very specifically
to an audience for a moment the problem
is when you're in a sort of a a niche or
like almost like an echo chamber and
then when suddenly the world's media
glares on it yeah a lot of stuff could
look bad that wasn't necessarily and I'm
not gonna pick out any specific things
that he may or may not have said but
things are taken out of context things
aren't taken without the benefit of you
know there was irony here there was
satire but this is one thing I want to
say to that like because you know what I
was saying about the intelligence thing
the only reason why I mentioned tennis
is because I do believe sometimes when
men are saying some things to women they
sometimes not all they do I do think
they do understand it but they want to
play tactical games around it like like
let's say let's say let's take an
argument with a girlfriend for example
now she can know exactly what she did
wrong but you're making her feel bad
like what you said earlier that you can
be gonna so because of that they could
have a defense mechanism or something
that makes them say I don't want to feel
wrong here and now so I'm going to say
whatever to to just to just so that I
can have a point and that's the only
factor that I was factoring in that
there's an element of women don't know
but there's also an element of some
women don't want to be wrong and that's
that's the only thing that I was trying
to like put out there that we should I
don't want us to underestimate sometimes
they do know what we're saying you know
let's listen
female ego is massive thank you yeah
yeah
female ego is massive and some of them
even though when they they act like how
many times you caught a girl and you
know she's like dead ass wrong and
there's no way out of it she's like yeah
well that's why you're a premature
ejaculator
that's why your dad left your mom yeah
yeah you failure you're a loser like him
but at the site at the same time though
it has to be said I mean Andrew and
interested as well but Andrew in
particular is such a great communicator
yeah such a great communicator to paint
this picture and to dramatize this this
that his his the way that he's
characterized this whole thing is him
against the Matrix they're doing this
look at the terrible things they're
doing look at what I'm like to to paint
that picture with that power and that
conviction that degree of conviction and
that articulously is incredibly
impressive and if you want to be
conspiratorial about it and why people
are why potentially the powers that be
would be worried about him it's because
you know you were saying that obviously
the mainstream media programs people in
a certain way but he's coming in a
pretty close second with a with a stream
like that it's really changing people's
mind about things and I I even think the
mainstream media is destructive like
what is social social media done for
women it makes us goddamn delusional it
makes us think we're hotter than we are
it makes us think we're thinner than
they are it literally dilutes how we
look at ourselves you know the cameras
make us better looking just does it
actually yes yes I thought that was a
study that said that if you look in the
mirror your brain tells you you five
times better looking than you actually
are like I thought I was just like yeah
but imagine that with a freaking don't
don't quote me I'm gonna imagine that
with a filter like women literally think
yeah that's 20 times better now when you
take a selfie it makes you better
looking yeah it makes you better looking
even Zoom puts filters on you all of
these mainstream media like they don't
care about what's true they just want to
paint a picture and they're doing that
to Tate
um and that's what I'm saying like this
is all again it's disgusting but
it's all lies and manipulation for money
you know if you want to get biblical too
right what's the what's the root of all
evil beloved money and if you see
everything that's happening around the
world these nasty low IQ baboons are
doing whatever they [__] can do to
get clicks to get views to get whatever
and they don't care who they have to
throw under the bus to get that and it's
absolutely despicable and the thing is
this too when someone Rises up and
they're an above average example to
humanity and above average success the
reality about life is this the majority
of people are losers I'm sorry I'll be
the one to say it the majority of people
are losers and their hate and vitriol
is manifested when they see someone
above them that's better than them
because when you become a successful
person all people in your life fall into
two categories
the award-winning [__] actor I met
this guy like 30 minutes ago but when
you become a super successful person
two people coming to your life people
who are envious of you or people who
want to learn from you yeah yeah you
know what I mean and that's it but it
goes back to a great quote by Arnold
Schwarzenegger and he said
everybody hideous the week yeah jealousy
you have to
earned
put a positive spin on that yeah
when I get some haters I'm like I bet
you do hate me down there in the lower
middle class like what you doing you
know what you were saying earlier on
about like there's two types of people
the ones that Envy you and the ones that
we want to learn from you yeah now let's
let's extrapolate that to like Society
in general because it is kind of not
necessarily a war that's going on but
something's happening right now yeah and
it's like what if 50 of those people are
against the battle why 50 are against
being bad as a person being stronger as
a person being more financially stable
as a person because it's now like I'm
look I'm looking at components that
could further make the battle difficult
like what about our own team members
because like we're preaching this member
we're preaching this message to everyone
but not everyone hears a message some
people hear insults some people hear oh
you're attacking me you're making me
feel bad we've got pretty much the
majority of women that hate Andrew Tate
plus 50 of guys that like those women
that now hvt yeah so so it's like how do
we then balance that because we could
spend you could spend all day shouting
at a class of a thousand students yo
make sure you get a job make sure you
become a lawyer make sure you do this
but a percentage is going to listen and
a percentage is going to disrupt the
class yeah so how do we then like go
around that battle but the thing is that
entry type is uh a worthy opponent yeah
for the mainstream because like he was
saying on that BBC interview I think he
was saying to Lucy um
when you watch this back and you look at
the comments underneath in the videos
you're going to see the most people
agree with that is actually that's
actually true isn't it yeah when you
look at the videos and then they turn
the comment section off yeah yeah yeah
yeah
but even that though like you can also
also argue that who controls the media
controls who likes Andrew because yes
you can say 95 of people like Andrew T
on videos but you can also see they
remove the comments so no one actually
knows that and when Paul's going out
into the public most of these girls
don't even know why they hate him so
it's like how do we actually balance out
the who who were putting the message
towards and so forth like in general if
you're ever gonna go to war or if you're
going to do any if you're going to get
into a scrap with other people at a club
you want all the members on your team to
be solid you do not want a guy that's
like yeah man I'm down to ride then the
other one's like I don't know he looks
kind of scary but no one was like oh I'm
down you want everyone to be like yo
we're going in that direction we're
going for that because we know that this
is wrong yeah so so but like no matter
how much you say it to them Yo when we
need to go to them if he's a I don't
want to say but if his [__] is a [__]
in it like you're not going to be able
to like change that so yeah that's the
only reason why like I'm just looking at
the components that I don't think like a
lot of people actually think about like
what about the people on our team yeah
and I think the the the internet has
added so many great things to
everybody's lives but the one bad thing
it's done is it's given a voice to
morons
wait wait wait did the did the stream
cut no no no the Andrew Tate tweeted the
power
house 15 minutes ago no
no The Matrix
this is actually right now
yo where the [__] is Morpheus man we're
at War right now
yes live wait wait yo that's what she's
scared wait I don't see it that way wait
wait wait yeah I know I wanna pull up
pull up the video I want to see when it
cuts
if Rumble breaks its live stream record
with 500 000 concurrent live viewers
I'm reading the news right now
yo that is actually mud does this sound
hot this is society right now we're in
an attention-based economy no no
he just said yeah 14 minutes ago it was
tweeted out the power in my house went
out from Cobra Tate on Twitter right now
of all the times in the world that's
crazy too much power they're tracking
him down no no no no no no no the Matrix
imagine 500 yeah
you can do that on YouTube who do you
have to how angry do you have to be to
call up the electric people
no I I think what I'm saying is just
like for anybody who for the whole thing
to actually like [__] cut out to
shows that everything he said is
freaking true about this one can we
watch it anywhere now that it's done
yeah we could watch it from the
beginning go where it cut I want to see
where it cut first imagine me someone
being angry eating quotes out the power
in your house
for today because we tell you to do that
because we make you a better version of
yourself so you can help everybody
pounds we'd be allowed to sit here
forever that's why they locked us in a
jail cell to suffer because we try and
[__] help people it's genuinely good
against evil this isn't about some
[__] case it's not about BBC and
Lucy or human trafficking no this is
genuinely good against evil and it
upsets me in my heart that we live in a
world now where the absolute evil is out
here not only trying to hurt us but hurt
everybody around us and everybody we try
and help not only you at home but also
all the people we rely on we have
children they're locking us in a jail
cell leaving our kids without fathers
for what what have we done to anybody
tick tock tick tock sitting here telling
you to be a better bird version of
yourself at the train hard to be
dedicated and they want to put us in a
jail cell it's disgusting what's
happened to us
hmm
oh
I will say this was out in every single
podcast if they lock me up for some
insane [__]
I didn't do it
the Matrix has attacked me
if I carry on with the trajectory I'm
carrying on they're gonna put me in jail
because I'm too influential for the
people watching a home they just need to
sit and understand that the system does
not make rules for the good of you that
makes rules for the good of the people
who make the rules and a lot of the life
paths laid out to the average man at
home today is not for their own good
it's only going to lead them to
depression and misery
facing some very serious allegations I
absolutely not really know I am a Force
for good because I'm a force for truth
and truth is a good thing without truth
we're going to end up in absolute
tyranny in slavery and we're already on
our way there
because a lot of men are largely
forgotten about
there's no evidence
does not be detained at this point there
are not even charges filed against them
the politician
I mean the best for people I want
everyone to be successful I want the
world to be a better place and I think
the world's a better place based on the
back of strong men who stand up for what
they believe in I think that's how the
world's always been a better place the
Matrix programming says the opposite to
be a better place all the men need to be
weaklings and compassionate without any
morals or without any hard lines or
beliefs and they must talk in a very
very soft way and we need to be very
very compassionate and very very
tolerant in all these things but if you
look at history the only times things
were peaceful and nice is when strong
men stood up with their swords and said
no this is mine this works this way and
no one's going to come [__] with it I
think that masculinity and strength is
what makes things beautiful is what
preserves things and so we need more of
this is what's missing from the world
masculine men have a duty to provide and
protect those they care about where you
have a duty to do things we don't feel
like doing because we know we're
supposed to do them and it's your duty
as a man to stand up and say I want to
be as important and strong and
good-hearted and God-fearing as possible
and I need to work hard to achieve those
things
if you cannot control your own mind then
you are just a feather in the Wind of
life because your own mind is the only
thing you can control you can't control
the weather you can't control other
people you can't even control whether
your heart stops beating you might have
a heart attack tomorrow you can't
control anything besides what you think
there's no such thing as too much
masculinity if it's genuinely masculine
genuine masculinity is not out here to
hurt people's absolutely the opposite
it's out here to protect and when bad
things happen they call traditionally
masculine men if you need a firefighter
you need a masculine man when you call
the police because of the problem you
have you want masculine men and as soon
as a woman or a man is in trouble when
you look for backup you look for
masculine men and masculine men have a
duty to provide and protect those they
care about we have a duty to do things
we don't feel like doing because we know
we're supposed to do them and that's why
we stayed in the Titanic and died and
the dangerous thing about overly
emotional men is that they're dangerous
they're genuinely dangerous this is
what's crazy all these people who talk
about toxic masculinity and how bad it
is for men to be traditionally masculine
a traditionally masculine man does
things he doesn't feel like doing
because it is his duty to do them
charges into the burning building
because it is his duty not because he
feels like it because it is his duty
we're now teaching the new generation of
men that they don't have duty and they
can just act on their feelings and act
how they feel and they don't have to act
as a man should do you know what happens
when you get men who just act how they
feel you get School shooters you get
violence you get rapists you do not
control their emotions are dangerous if
you find a man who is stoic he's not
going to hurt people he's going to sit
and think about his actions very
carefully he needs to be a good man who
protects for it and provides for his
family you find a man who just acts out
on impulse and does whatever he feels
like you're gonna find a dangerous man
sitting here telling men to cry more and
act with their feelings and it's okay to
feel this way that way Etc and have no
self-control that is why we have the
problems we have in the world absolutely
not only wrong so when they talk about
toxic masculinity they have it
completely inversed on its head
completely Nutley wrong we need to be
teaching stoicism we're going to be
teaching young men to understand that
the world is very very difficult it's
hard to be a man you're going to feel
bad sometimes you just suck up and
perform anyway
[Music]
hmm
we live in a comfortable world now where
people think oh it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter but you know what to some
degree it does matter it does matter and
I'll tell you who it matters to it
matters to your soul and it matters to
God I stand in the mirror with a pure
heart I know I am the best version of me
that could possibly ever exist I know
that God is proud of me there's nothing
that God hates more than sloth and
laziness if God were to create a man and
that man were to sit around and do [__]
all God will frown upon you it's why
you're never lucky start to work start
to show God the beauty of his own
Creations you'd be amazed how lucky
you'll become we talk about depression
anxiety that comes from self-loathing
you loathe your own weakness you load
your own laziness that's what all of
these things are I don't feel depression
how can I feel depression when I'm the
most powerful version of me that I could
ever [__] be how can I feel
depression when I could squeeze my own
hand hard enough to break my own bones
how can I feel depression when I've
slashed and destroyed 68 people's faces
in front of me men who thought they
could test me in Fair combat how can I
feel depressed it's impossible
[Music]
wow
but I love the idea of one day perhaps
in 50 years from now one of my sons
doing a stream about me telling the
things I used to say and how I had an
impact on the world said Avengers end
games think about how the world is going
to be in 50 years when they say remember
when top G first came and he's the
reason I got rich and he's the reason I
went to the gym and they tried to ban
him but they couldn't the story of of
top G and the story of me is going to be
a long and very very interesting one
we're at the very beginning we're at
stage one of a three-stage plan
I hate everything that's going on like
loving with all my heart yeah like I'll
die on that mountain with you bro yeah
let's get on that Hill where's the sword
why is he's why is the the Enemy of the
State so to speak
he's got the hearts of young men I feel
like men nowadays need an Andrew Tate
the guy who's motivating men to be men
if you cannot control your own mind then
you go through life with zero control
zero influence you can't control
anything you're just a feather in the
wind waiting for life to blow you from
happy place to sad place to happy place
to sad Place completely hoping on the
gods to be fortunate to you because of
Any genuine discomfort comes your way
you're [__]
it's so easy to win if you can control
your own mind but it seems that nobody
[__] can
and that's how the people who run the
world keep the world running because
they have all the slaves exactly where
they need them to be permanently
distracted and semi-depressed working
their asses off in jobs which will never
satisfy them and never pay enough money
that's the Matrix
[Music]
we are fighting a battle and is
absolutely gnarly important because the
battle is for your mind and once you
lose your mind
you don't get it back
yo well well let's see what happens here
one question is overwhelming the chat
Andrew and I think you need to come back
to where we were 30 minutes ago in this
podcast I said I would never give up on
the people I said I would never give up
on our fans I said I will not just take
my hundreds of millions of dollars and
Run to the Hills I said I would never
quit but you never actually answered the
question you're rich you're strong
you've got a family you've got me you
could disappear from this we could
delete all of our internet profiles
tomorrow we could vanish from the
internet and we would live amazing lives
incomparable to most Lives Many Men
would ever live electricity so I guess
the question that everyone's looking for
an answer to
is what are you going to do
I know the answer but I need to tell
them this is you know what makes me sad
if I thought crying was constructive I
would cry but it's not who I am I don't
think it's constructive I don't think
it's the correct thing to do but I'm not
sad for myself I'm prepared to suffer
I've built a life in which I must suffer
but I am sad for the people around me
and I'm sad because I know this Matrix
attack has just begun and I'm sad
because I know they're going to try and
push this to the end they're going to
genuinely try and put us in jail for no
reason I'm sad that other countries out
there which I love which I grew up in
which I'm patriotic to which I have the
passport to are out to get me and hurt
me for no reason other than the fact I'm
trying to do good I'm sad for the people
around me who I love who rely on me not
just on me for money but also for my
presence as a whole I'm sad they want to
take me away from my [__] children
I'm sad they want to leave me to Raw in
a hole for what what for and I'm sad
that they want to turn me into a coward
and I either have to go and live and sit
in my room with all my money and try and
distract myself with Hedonism and a
bunch of women or go on a boat and
delete my Twitter account and just shut
up and be and be a happy coward or I
have to sit and be a sad hero and
there's no in between that's what I'm
sad about that's what really upsets me
that I'm left with those two choices I'm
either a hero who must suffer endlessly
this is just the beginning none of this
is going away you think this is going
away so this is the beginning of all of
it it's never gonna [__] end they're
gonna continue to attack me for the End
of Time No Matter What They're Gonna
Keep doing it to me and I'm sad that my
children are going to wake up every day
wondering if dad's in jail for no reason
or if Dad's been assassinated yet you
think they're going to allow me to
continue to spread good when they're
truly evil in their hearts I'm putting a
bullet in my head I'm sad knowing that I
got the best life on earth and the only
thing I have to do is be a coward to
live it but I don't want to [__] wake
up every day looking over my shoulder
worried about being killed on the
alternative to it is to wake up every
day and feel like a [__] [__]
because I don't tell the truth I'm left
with two [__] choices why for following
God for telling people to be a good
person it's disgusting what's happening
to me I'm sad not for me I'm sad for
everybody around me it's disgusting
I don't know
they'll have to kill me first if there
was a if there was a choice
there's not even a choice in my mind I I
can't live at the coward I can't live
with the person I can't sell my sanity I
can't throw my brain away and sit out
here and just [__] lie to everybody
and tell them to be slaves like
everybody else can I can't put on a
Pokemon costume and be a [__] clown I
can't be that person I have to be the
person who tells the truth that tries to
improve the world I've always done my
best to help people we donate so much
money to charity name another person
name one detractor or one person who
hates us who's donating a penny to
anybody who's feeding anybody none of
them are nobody cares it's just you and
me were the only people out here doing
it
all the people who are after us now for
money and these fake charges and this
fake garbage that was trying to steal
all our wealth what will they do with it
will they donate it to charity will they
help anybody of course not they have no
interest in helping anybody we're the
only ones out here genuinely trying to
help people and I'm sad that that
affects the people I love most that's
what makes me sad
well I'm by your side it won't
negatively affect me if I have to sit in
jail I'll sit in jail
they're gonna shoot you I'll stand in
the way we go down together
come on hey it's always been that way
for you and me my friend and that's what
they're most jealous of is the fact that
you and I have something that most
people don't have which is genuine
Brotherhood and that's what they fear
most when you have men who have aligned
principals who respect those principles
more than life itself that's what
they're afraid of shout out to my
friends as well absolutely and that's
what they're afraid of they're afraid
that we can't be bought they have tried
to buy us and we won't sell that's what
they're afraid of that's what they're
most afraid of and they'll continue to
be most afraid of
who's this where it cuts
all right so I don't think the power
outage no I think that that's where it
cuts Yeah well yeah because he takes his
his headphone off so that kind of looks
like they wanted to pull it yeah and
then I I don't think uh I mean if the
power's out they're they're out to
[__] kill him but oh I don't think it
was cut because because you know why
would you take your headphones up like
when do you take your headphones off in
the middle of the show and be like [__]
it this is just pearly thing so we'll do
it without my headphones no not usually
I don't know that looks like it was off
and then he he did just tweet out in
addition to that like get on my mailing
list which is a solid call to action
right now after having 500 000 people
there which is is a good uh and I guess
cobrotate.com forward slash newsletter
he said we'll send a very important
update to the email list in exactly 11
hours sign up now so I don't think it
was a matrix attack like that shut down
this the the stream because that just
seems like you just stopped the stream
yeah it looked like you just stopped
straight you're about to get up and go
somewhere yeah yeah he took it and then
they played that that was a very
I wanted to start doing some push-ups
right now I'll be honest that that video
Pearl knows this because she was there
uh I lost my father to cancer recently
and Paul came to the funeral this is the
end of last year
and
I'm very close to my family I have a big
family
and everyone including myself was
absolutely heartbroken of course
absolutely heartbroken my siblings
uncles aunties cousins everyone because
my dad was the leader of the family if
they have the family when anybody needed
anything they went to him right and he
instilled a lot of principles in me
Etc
what he's saying about a level of
stoicism I took this from Jordan
Peterson as well
everyone was breaking down I was the one
who sawed everything everything it's
part of my responsibility because I'm
the eldest and I'm the eldest son I come
from Nigerian family yeah my aunties are
uncles breaking down siblings everyone I
did everything yeah right with the help
of my cousin and someone else but I was
spare pointing everything was I
heartbroken of course I was but someone
has to [__] do it it's masculine Duty
someone has someone has to do it it's
masculine Duty and it's like even now
like I have a little brother who's five
it's Father's Day this Sunday I'm gonna
take him out because he's like he's
growing up without a dad yeah someone
has to step up to the plate yeah and so
what he's saying about now yeah when I
had my own time I grieved in my own time
when I was by myself yeah but when I was
out that door I had a duty to fulfill to
my family yeah and my friends Pearl was
at the funeral right there was like 200
people there
right and it's not even that I'm still
not the inheritance his assets
everything I'm sorting everything out
and what he's saying about an essence of
masculinity it's not about not engaging
or not having emotions but I think part
of being a man is taking responsibility
for other people and in order to do that
there is a level of commitment and due
to you have to have there
right and there's a place and time for
everything so that video I just saw here
is a 100 correct and like some and I
I've always been the kind of guy who's
been on my [__] on my [__] and I've been
very blessed in my journey but like
there's a saying they say um they say
a boy only becomes a man when he buries
his father yeah and
when I buried my father I realized the
reason that is is because
spiritually or anything the mantle is
now handed to you and
what when your father dies the little
boy who you were dies with him does that
make sense and my mom is crying my mom I
think it's my parents divorce when I was
a baby and they weren't close and I'll
I'll end this story here with this
friend
but the reason she was crying yes she
was upset because you know the father of
her child died but she was like I'm not
ready for the man this is going to turn
you into
because I want to still see you as my
little boy yeah you see what I'm saying
so I'm just saying just as antidote to
experience but everything he said in
that trailer he is 100 correct but yeah
and what you just said too it kind of
ties into what you're saying earlier
about relationships like no matter what
when it comes to a marriage or
relationships your duty is to the cause
which is we came together yes to walk
this life journey together to endure
together to go through the hardships
together that's why the Bible says and
all the whatever religion you want to
talk about for richer for poor for
better for worse right because if you're
a person again going back to what I've
said earlier if you're a person that
lives based upon your emotions yeah your
life is going to be awful it's gonna be
absolutely for when I was building my
business I started my YouTube channel
2015 and from 2015 to January of 2019 I
had 880 subscribers it was awful I felt
dumb I felt incompetent I felt like dude
am I just a person with no value am I
just a valueless [__] uploading this
[__] and trying to make it happen but I
knew that at the end of the day I wanted
to make things happen on YouTube it has
been on my vision board it was in my
mind movies it was in my my you know
written statement that I keep in my
wallet it was in all these things and
there had been numerous times where I
was just like I just want to quit
because I'm tired of feeling like a
loser I'm tired of feeling like a stupid
idiot yeah but I knew that quitting
would guarantee my failure and not
quitting
gave me a fighting chance and from 2019
to where I am now you know
Monumental success yeah Monumental
success I believe that what I've taken
from both of you guys like like um the
testimonies you just put forward and
sorry for your father's loss as well I
do want to say that yeah appreciate it
what I've taken from that is that like
as a man responsibility is important and
I think it comes down to a biological
level as well that we need to feel
responsible if you look at a lion with
their with their they run the pack and
their animals yeah so to to to to a
biological level it's important for men
to feel like they are responsible and I
feel like the generation that we're in
now were selling a false dream to people
making them feel like oh you don't have
to be as responsible you can just just
relax let the girls just just relax like
everyone else and you see that but I
think that biological component of I
have to feel responsible you know how
powerful it is to feel that you can look
your your father's funeral in the face
and say my emotions don't matter
that is a massive thing and that comes
down to your wiring as a person because
like no matter like I've got sisters
I've got like you know I have a mother I
have Auntie so forth I don't expect them
to have the ability to just handle my
father's death right or to be able to
just take over things and just move
forward like nothing's happened but us
as men we don't have not say that we
don't have the choice but we're wired to
be able to do that the same way a woman
is wired to able to handle that child a
lot better than some fathers are made
for shoulders no hips that's what I'm
saying so it's like I feel like this is
why we do need to be pushing the message
of men need to be more responsible and
accountable yeah it's also a message of
generally a message of stoicism isn't it
yeah they they talk about stoicism a lot
in their content and uh we are living in
an age where emotionalism is the is is
the sort of number one factor of the day
yesterday I mean like I'm in my feelings
yeah it's my truth yeah Etc I guess you
know watching that what what fight
really stands against is this
emotionalism the effects not only
women but also guys you guys are also
and and and he's saying no you need to
be stomach you need to take a step back
and you need to not live in your
feelings because sometimes you you need
to step up to the plate and by the way
again you know I I you know great
condolences for for what you for what
you share about but that was a very very
moving and very um heavy profound
actually thing that you should just and
then I think the reality of the
situation is too I think your father
would have it no other way no other way
no other way like because because if you
if the roles are reversed he would do
the exact same thing 100 and like he he
led by example so I saw that and I'm
just because when his father died he's
not even the eldest sibling but that's
exactly what he did yeah that's exactly
what he did yeah and I think I think
it's like I was born right here but I
come from a Nigerian family so I have a
both like Nigerian culture and a western
culture and I'm gonna get some hate for
this but I I do believe it's true I feel
unfortunately especially with like the
black community in the west right in
terms of we're talking like single
motherhoods and stuff like that and
don't get me around there's a level of
systematic stuff that happened you know
through decades yeah but there's an
element of
ultimately as men we are responsible for
that Community amen we are responsible
for it so if stuff is not going right
it's because we're not doing what we
need to do and taking responsibility and
putting the boundaries here stepping out
to Plate here etc etc like just
personally for me like I could never
donate my sperm to a sperm bank because
any child of mine is my responsibility
yeah that's mine yeah it's my
responsibility I could never do that
yeah do you know what I mean so I just
it I think we have to to a level we have
to stick step up to the plate and that's
the example we need Andrew Tate's doing
that for men why don't you think they
celebrate masculinity because because
it's a threat it's a threat
who who started World War II
men men
who finished
or two man okay we are the most useful
deadly force on this planet and they're
just trying to monopolize manhood when
you look at look at the government all
this [__] they say about like you
know violence is not the answer and
don't do this and violence is never the
way um
who has a monopoly on violence in
society if you don't pay your taxes
they'll drag you and lock you in a cell
if you don't follow the laws they'll
[__] kill you yeah you know so men
men are the ones men are and probably
talk about studies all the time that you
do right men are the ones that are the
most disagreeable in society oh yeah you
know what I mean men are the ones that
always push back and men are the ones
who consistently lead revolutions like
yeah please name one female-led
revolution
I guess the feminism probably that's not
a revolution
yeah
feminism was funded by the CIA too it
was funded by the CIA
who enforces feminism man that's the
only way you can enforce it yes it's go
you go yeah man
this is the first time you did something
masculine and we're shamed for it being
oh
they're like a woman or like Society
like you noticed like wow I can't I
can't do this or maybe a girl shamed you
like what was the first time you can
give a perspective and be shamed okay
somebody sucker punched my friend in a
pizza joint in Orlando after we were
drinking and uh I whip that guy's ass
and I whooped his friend's ass and then
there's a girlfriend of mine which is
just like you shouldn't have done that
I'm like my friend got punched in the
face like I'm not a [__] [__] I
gotta defend my friend's honor wow
sometimes I get set up to have to be the
bad guy like like it could be a thing of
if I go for this way of doing it or the
complete opposite of way doing it I
still like look at that guy regardless
yeah I think that that's just like I
think the reason why that gets put on us
a lot more is because because we're seen
as the top heads of things it's easier
to put more responsibility on us but I
think to some degree people misbalance
it yeah and then they can end up like
putting an unrealistic expectation on us
yeah yeah and like what's happening with
this role of tomasi says this often and
it's pretty true when he says right now
they're trying to push responsibility on
men while stripping them of authority
100 yeah that responsibility and
Authority needs to come hand in hand
because you know like if you get
reprimanded at your boss I reprimanded
work by your boss right yeah but your
boss can't fire you'd be like yo [__]
you bro I'm not gonna do whatever you're
gonna tell me what to do but the fact
that he has the authority yeah to demote
Yahoo or or transfer you to [__]
Uganda or whatever and ruin your
situation with your income or your
livelihood his authority is also
directly tied to his responsibility and
that's why it's hilarious too when I go
to the states when I go fresh to fit and
I talk to all these psychotic American
feminist women and they're just like no
matter what it reminds me of the episode
of of uh Fresh Prince of Bel Air when
will was in trouble and they're like
that's his family's motto when in doubt
blame will it's like an American women
when in doubt just blame men
when have you ever heard when have you
ever heard an American woman or a woman
in general be like you know what
things didn't work out me and my ex but
let me first tell you things that I did
wrong
s that she did wrong and it made the
news
[Laughter]
problem in a relationship New York Times
woman takes accountability wow
like response I think Andrew Tate said
this responsibility without Authority is
slavery is
um yeah it is slavery and that's what
they want well you just said before
about women and taking accountability
and stuff I literally just got to the
accountability stage the other day you
know what 26 years
and I just said to myself my love life
didn't work out and I don't think it's
because of men I think it's because of
me I have good guys bad guys in between
but I get entertained by the ones that
are more difficult scenario like it's
just like we're playing mind games on
and off all this toxicity you like the
bad boys
because it still hurts but it's like
I've definitely entertained people that
had red flags written all over them well
for no reason do you okay so do you it's
interesting when girls when we take
accountability
I gotta say this it's always I choose
toxic men not the toxic behaviors that
we play
um
accountability if you're just saying I'm
entertaining the toxic men
it takes two to tango yeah I've been in
a toxic relationship before and I was
toxic yeah absolutely you can't you
can't be with someone for more than
maybe three a month or two three months
tops yeah without being toxic together
and blaming it on them and saying they
just made me toxic no like toxic people
don't do toxic but you know what it's
even more subtle than that isn't it
because it's a kind of like it's a it's
a half sort of admitting it's a
half-taking accountability like uh yeah
you know I I kind of entertained the
wrong guys but then it's just because
they're toxic she is also early in the
stage though
and been with was um I was 18 and he was
28. so he already had a one-up on me
because he okay so we're gonna test this
right now we're gonna test this right
now your past relationship that ended
what was wrong what was one thing you
did that you could have done differently
to make it a better relationship
not chosen the toxic guy
and then after that we're gonna put your
Instagram on this on the main screen
[Laughter]
I've learned a lot but um the red flags
I could have definitely paid attention
I know but the thing is I definitely
thought like I was naive a bit okay
because I what happened like what what
ended the relationship it was on and off
because instead of him communicating
with me he would give punish me with
silent treatment and blocking and then
my emotions will be up and down okay
what what did you do to have him block
you
um okay I'll give you an example I went
on a girls trip okay okay pause pause
pause
okay okay okay with one girl yeah and I
basically saw him the day before and I
told him communicated everything to him
and the day before the day before I'm
flying out he didn't even give him more
notice like oh yeah okay wait so okay so
you're seeing a girl this is cooking up
you know so so wait did you did you ask
him if you could go on the girls trip
yeah yeah and he said yes yes and he
said yes okay so I now went I said with
one girl I spoke to him before that and
everything was fine I went over there he
um hacked my phone I found out when I
got back he hacked my phone okay
um but when I got there I was sending
him snaps like I'm looking cute look at
me look at this look at that he was
giving me off Behavior he was being a
bit standoffish out of nowhere he
decided to block me and I'm like oh my
God my feelings are hurt
usually when girls tell the story it
sounds like there's more to the story it
doesn't seem like he would just block
you I don't know
men don't just leave girls you know like
you see when it comes to like um like
obviously I'm not saying that oh I do
you know how your situation went in it
but I'm saying in general yeah when it
comes to like relationships a man will
normally leave or block a girl when his
head is absolute limit with her like
even it because a guy okay cool let's
say that you catch a guy cheating yeah
and he's like oh he pissed me off your
chair like he's not gonna be like okay
let's just block each other to to fix
however yeah like nine times out of ten
he's gonna tolerate you know whatever he
got him because you know like so then
it's like in this scenario you know when
you say that oh boom like he just
blocked me like I I know what it's like
to be a guy in it like you know what
it's like to be a guy in it you know
it's like do you know what it's like to
be an emotional guy though because I
feel like this guy was very emotional
this is the thing like this is the thing
I've been I've been with a guy that's
emotional right and I've been in that
like I've been in a toxic relationship
like I'm not that same maybe he was a
hacking my phone but like but like you
have to you have to but like you cannot
like until you get through your head
that you cannot be in a toxic
relationship without being toxic you'll
never learn and you'll never grow
because there's no way that he you're
just the victim he just hacked your
phone like there's things that you did
that were probably drama-filled probably
attention seeking there there was
something you did and like like if
you're a healthy individual I know what
I did
oh I know why it's his brothers
don't do that I don't like those phrases
anyway
um yeah I'm a respectful Muslim women
please wait wait
how did he hack your phone can we talk
about this for a second yeah what it was
hacking was he tracking you on iCloud oh
no basically I don't I don't think I
should share this information with
people because it just just is it was it
an app no basically there's a thing
where you have an iPhone or an Android
he can do something to my phone put his
number in there
okay
he's done that and I think what I've
done is
um I was just always looking good
posting my Snaps looking cute and I
think that was triggering him because
let me let me just say like this is this
is why this translates to guys you were
acting like a hoe yeah
there's no skin out it's just face my
head
it's still advertising this is how men
see it yes you might not like it and you
know a lot of us have never been taught
this stuff okay but because we've never
heard what men think but so you to men
this is you're acting like a hoe and
then you get blocked yeah
at the same time hold on wait wait
listen and this is the thing like like
we can't move forward in life unless we
could see where we went wrong in certain
situations and I'll tell you this from
like personal experience like there's
times I've been listening to a guy on
the show and I'll think wow I like did
like this is where I went wrong like
I've apologized to people before you
know I'm always open-minded to learn I
never looked at it from that aspect the
way I see it's like from when my boobs
and everything is not out on this screen
yeah and you can just see my face and my
you said you said he's an emotional guy
but you said that you you told him the
day before you were going on the girls
trip right yeah so where was the girls
trip so Portugal I want more information
I want more information
is it okay what's your Instagram right
now let me look at it this I'm just
honey
wait can we put it on the screen I wanna
I wanna react
to see the type of stuff you post okay
hold on hold on hold on guys I am on a
journey of like becoming more religious
I am going to Rebrand my Instagram
honey
okay thank you put in the Instagram
guys
I am
j-u-s-t-h-a-n-i and then your honor the
evidence I'd like to present to the
court is uh picture number five from the
top and picture number one
pretty pretty Haram do you want to
please please
I don't this is this is was this the
type of stuff you were you were posting
uh look at that picture in the middle
that's Haram right there oh why are you
showing your backside to the world yeah
that's the that's Mickey still
you know I think it is yeah Instagram
girls that's that's not crazy about it
no but it's still Haram it's still to
some degree okay look it's Haram as in
as in like okay you could see a bit of
blacks you can see a bit of hair but
however even with that most people would
have been like oh my God this is not
even nothing we're in the westernized
society
I'm just gonna do you see how your gut
reaction isn't to listen it's to defend
yourself yeah
like oh maybe it is a bit haramic
wait wait you're still waiting turn off
for Mike
which which is fine you know all right
we all start something
you're doing it again
calm down you need a drink this is my
life guys I battled this in my head all
the time eventually yeah but it's like
it's like if that's your initial
response that's probably contributed
something because like if you think your
exes could have told you something
yeah that you didn't like we're
strangers and you're yelling at us yeah
like you would have you would have just
listened
and you would have just said okay if we
asked your exes if we called you no no I
feel like I would be definitely
described as defensive I have this thing
I grew up with seven siblings yeah it
was always cussing each other yeah but
see this is this is what women do too so
you're still now you're saying well it's
how I grew up and so now it's like it's
not on you it's on someone else I've
done stuff before too it's okay but it's
something that I can change but as far
as let's go back to my Instagram goes I
battled this with myself as well so I'm
like okay I do
um I used to have way more pictures no
archived and everything and I'm
literally like slowly finding a way to
you know become more more distressed I
think it's a perspective thing you know
and it's not a bad idea all the time
with myself and that's I'm not saying
that's not a bad thing that's good yeah
but I'm just saying when we look back at
situations if we're always like pointing
the finger we can't grow we can't get
better yeah let's let's ask the chat
Chad if you think her Instagram is Haram
Pusher one
push it two right there I'm right now
for not wearing a headscarf so let's
start there
we're in a Christian Nation okay so wait
well I guess I guess you're Muslims yeah
sad battle myself a lot more than but
you know what I think it is though I
generally think here that the issue here
isn't necessarily intentional or
malicious I think it's just a
perspective thing in this generation I
don't feel like a lot of women learn how
men are like or how they think or like
what their desires are so so it's like
the way it can translate across is that
oh wait I see that men like big boobs so
that was clearly what they want us but
if females actually sit down with men
and say what would you want from a wife
now you know from your Instagram
um early one you can 100 argue it's not
that deep you know you can argue on one
side of the coin but on the flip side of
the coin you can also argue wait the
action she's faced away from the screen
got a bomb to the screen yeah the
intention let's say that you don't it
doesn't matter what she's wearing let's
say the intention alone how could people
perceive it could we perceive it as
that's a woman that's got a husband and
that's a woman that you know is in a
relationship or could we perceive it as
oh she's single like what I'm saying how
long ago I think this is a perspective
thing
um three years ago I would have never
get back with him oh this is three years
ago yeah but he he would always come
back I thought you said you know he'd
always come back wait wait I thought you
said he was eight you were 18 he was 28.
but so how aren't you 26 yeah so then
you would have been 23 is this a
different X yeah so okay yeah okay so
I've been with him for like four years
so so when you were you were 22 you got
with him for four years no 18 I go with
it no no the last X how long were you
with it Portugal X this was the main
service relationship I would consider in
my life the rest was like getting to
know you okay okay
how old were you when you met him how
old were you when you met him when did
you break up 18 we had an on and off
relationship up until 22 23 I would say
Okay okay so 20 18 to 22. yeah that'd
answer your question no
wait so eight 18 to 20s you dated him
for four years on and off so on and off
that means the relationship was [__] but
the sex was good no no the one
actually I'm a blank right now four
years of this wow that's you I don't are
you a virgin
yes
do we have a stop
what what I don't know okay no
disrespect we shouldn't even have this
discussion no no no no no nothing about
me right now now to be fair it's for me
yeah I'm just learning it because this
is a completely different Insight
because you because you're coming with
having background yeah and you've got a
different these types of insights behind
you yeah this sounds pretty different to
me like for example you've been saying
like you're 26 right now your virgin
we're in a western Society I haven't
heard that since I was like 15. that's
something's Like a Virgin this so that's
some reason why like we're asking and
it's like
this is the thing as well they're
surprised because you don't portray
yourself like a virgin which is which is
a which is a great you know based on
that you're born are you important I'm
not saying I'm not saying it's like a
well is she a born-again version they
don't they don't believe you but I'm
saying there's a reason they think your
cat don't be stupid yeah I think you're
capping no okay thank you I'm copying
for my Instagram but no one has virgin
on it no but I'm saying no yeah but
usually like I've had virgin girls come
on the show where nobody really nobody
really like wait wait nobody really like
pushes back right but it's not like it's
just it's a good thing right that's like
a great thing I think that's awesome it
is good but it's like it's like
unfortunate because I'm like No One
Believes you because of the Instagram
it's like it's like it loses but yeah
that's a great thing nobody has that no
that's why I want to change my Instagram
too
I'm gonna go home and archive that
picture okay
I'm just gonna give you the chance right
now honey do you remember the
conversation we had before the cameras
were on
what do you mean what conversation about
the situation you told me about I don't
remember we was just talking in general
no but do you remember about the
situation you told me about that I was
giving you advice on
it was a general situation I can't
remember exactly where the word bulk
what does that have to do with this part
because you just told everyone here
something that from that situation I was
that what were you talking about because
I wasn't talking about me and myself in
that situation you you were I don't let
out you because I know the camera maybe
you don't want to you don't want people
to know what you're talking about
honestly I was talking about situation
with my friend just in general but I
don't know I just met you do I know you
look don't be rude to me yeah because
I'm not trying to be don't be rude to me
but I'm just I'm just trying to say some
sort of no I haven't I haven't hold on
I've not said anything about anything
yeah I'm just saying do you remember the
conversation that we had I remember some
of the conversations we had yeah most of
them yeah this is like a politician
isn't it yeah
this conversation this was about an hour
ago so you you remember all of it then
don't you yeah yeah okay you know you're
saying I remember something I remember
the conversation you remember I was
talking about a lot of things yeah okay
but no but we specifically were talking
about a situation that I was giving you
advice on we were talking about for
about 45 minutes right I was talking
about about a certain things in my
situation that was your situation no it
wasn't stop the cab
you know
I apologize if that was the case but you
could come check the label on my suit
it's it costs more than your outfit
hey guys guys guys guys let me just see
okay before hey okay cool well let me
say this you know the reason why I
thought there could just be a bit of
tension right now and a bit of
disagreements only because earlier when
you were speaking about the city um girl
situation or the holiday thing that
happened I remember at one point you did
also say oh and then that happened and
it's not me saying that you're a liar or
anything like that it's just that within
this limited time I've known you yeah if
I if someone says a story then misses
out a story I can only go off my
imagination and it doesn't necessarily
mean that I'm tying you or saying yo
straight home straight this did it it's
not that but you have to remember all of
us not all of us but all a lot of us are
just meeting each other for the first
time and we're going off of you see
first impressions are the most important
because they're the ones that stick the
longest so obviously in regards to the
Instagram it's not even like I've looked
at Instagram and said yo you're dressed
mad it's not even that it's just that
when you say I'm a virgin and then
there's quite a few westernized
similarities like it's just in common
sense similarities like do you see how
someone that's a stranger could be like
oh maybe I don't I don't understand no
if she's a virgin not black yeah that's
fine but that's you lots opinion yeah
yeah that's fine everyone could have
different opinions yeah yeah you can't
insult my guest I apologize for him
because I thought he was coming for me
and to calling me a liar that's why okay
okay I'm not here to disrespect anyone
but I just felt a bit attacked so I was
defending myself he wasn't he wasn't
attacking you I just because when he
kept saying I know you felt but it's
like you keep having this like visceral
reaction you can stay because you
apologize okay
if you want to you can say but but you
can't you can't you can't insult my
guests like that's it's not but you
would you would deflecting as well
because it seemed like there was some
opposing evidence to what you're saying
no it wasn't it was just everyone just
putting their little two cents in and um
it wasn't you guys don't know it wasn't
facts as well so it was just a bit like
I'm saying what I'm saying you know she
just respect what I'm saying whether you
believe it or not and just call it a day
that's it just but to some degree though
like it's it's like to some of you I
accept that that's fair it's just that
to some degree though it is a it's a
public podcast that we're all just
putting opinions forward in it like it's
normal that someone can put an opinion
for you and if I think yo boom I don't
really agree with that or I don't I
could be wrong you know but it's it's
for you to be able to be like you know
what yeah you may not be agreeing with
me but this is a podcast isn't it but
it's like but people are just gonna have
something to say against what you've got
to say and of course that's that's why
I'm on social media I already know that
people are gonna say they stand out
about me so it's okay it's cool where's
my best actor or Jay because I need to
hand it over real quick
you guys had a conversation before the
show we had a conversation
I'm gonna ask him questions and I'll ask
you questions so so this conversation
this conversation
[Laughter]
so so this conversation you don't have
to tell me what she said but it's
basically contradicting what she's
saying now
[Music]
um
there are some things that she has said
on this podcast right that does not
align with things she that we discussed
but it's her life I will not disclose
anything that she said because we were
discussion I was hoping through a
situation so I wouldn't disclose
anything because if she doesn't want it
to be public that's fine but that's why
I was asking her do you remember the
conversation because it doesn't some
things are not aligning you know this
happens
yeah
okay I've warned you I told you I told
you I'm going to ask you questions in a
second okay cool no I need you this is
I've warned you you gotta go
all right that's fine I'll just go
because this is just feeling a bit like
too much of an attack okay okay
um
okay okay that's fine just go it's fine
Troy I'll come sit next to you
please
I need a hug now
uh yeah that's what they're saying
they're like why'd you bring up bring it
up it's like
I'm gonna get it today no you don't you
know what's funny though
okay do you know what's funny though
this happens to me all the time on the
show this happens to me all the time
where like someone will say something
but I don't want to say anything yeah I
can yeah yeah I I saw it in real time no
no and it's like yeah so I I know what
you mean I think ultimately no go ahead
ultimately
like like
talking some people
knew oh mine no no that one like this
but yeah if you're coming on the podcast
you should know what you're saying look
listen like Everyone's entitled to their
privacy Etc that but I'm a bit like oh
boy if you've said something I don't
know like if you said something that I'm
like ah I was just that's why I said
look I'm just saying do you remember the
conversation does the truth trigger
people
or do lies trigger people like what
which one is it what's inside are we
talking about this one the British one
ah depends on the truth
well I mean it's a little bit
disingenuous if you're going to come on
to a show and say something that's I
mean
that you you're directly contradicting
something that you've revealed to
somebody else yeah just prior to that
show well particularly particularly if
it's something that you're trying to
cast yourself in a good light
yeah
I understand because I'm like nobody
expected her to be a virgin you know
what I mean like yeah that's it I didn't
say that's what it was just for the
record I didn't say that's what it was
that was she was white a virgin
just accept what comes with it and so I
was projecting and maybe Troy gentlemen
you guys could agree with me or not I
have been in on and off relationships
with girls and the only thing that was
keeping us both there was really good
sex like yeah
Mr kitten do you agree with me you're
the dating coach or no you disagree like
if it's on and off it's like you're
having sex but it's not a commitment but
that was not it well okay so then and
I'm open to understanding the truth so
like what we're on and off was why did I
stay what was the on and off about and
was it the sex mediocre or
um
no
no I don't know
bro you got to get off the shelter get
the [__] out of here get out of here
[Laughter]
sorry Mr Pearl sorry sorry
Mr Davis it was all right it wasn't
great so what is the context of the off
and on like what happened
um
it was just like maybe I'd like go
through his phone and find something I
didn't like you know I was kind of I was
kind of looking for problems if I'm
being honest yeah and I really would
overreact about a lot of stuff what did
you find when you went through his phone
um I don't
um you know like messages that sort of
thing but two other girls
partially but I I think I kind of
overreacted on a lot of them like it
wasn't really that deep were you
overreacting because you wanted to find
a reason to overreact or was it just
because you were triggered emotionally
um
interesting yeah it's interesting
because I was thinking why is it so many
girls will go through guys photos and
it's insecurity right yeah I've had
girls I had a girlfriend like every
single girl that I've ever dated really
used to would go through my phone and
there was one girl I was dating and she
would like literally every time she came
round she'd go oh yeah I've seen
something on your phone you know it's
very it's very like it's addicting you
got to get your next fix that's what I
realized I was like I keep like like if
I like I obviously don't care because I
keep we keep getting back together and I
keep looking for problems yeah is she
still here or what is she like no I
think she laughed it's King was she
taken out
okay
um what did she say bro tell us
your favorite listen I'm sorry listen
listen that I don't think she's a virgin
I think she knows people that are going
to see her on social media and she's
gonna get shamed for being a shitty
Muslim I I have never met someone such
with such a visceral reaction
like virgins don't know how to be that
toxic
that comes from trauma I've had virgin
like girls come on the show and yeah
they're very Meek they're like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're very Meek
you know you can you can tell
um
I see it's consistent for me like I see
too many times that she say something
then someone else will say something to
be like oh I just remember this happened
to you I was like okay I could tell you
I could tell you uh
give us the team give us the British
team this isn't anything crazy but she
was she was like telling me a story
about like a guy or whatever that shared
history with and then she was saying
about how like her sister he then I
think she called it off so then he went
for her sister right and I was like oh
wow that's like kind of mad that's
really weird and I was like you know I
had that happen I was like oh this
happened she was like you know my sister
got his number I was like wait your your
sister got his number
she was like yeah I was like how did she
get his number so oh well I gave her
gave it to her I was like wait I'm
confused so did he go after your sister
or did your sister go after him
because she was like he was like oh well
you know a pet she was like oh well he
said no because her sister said no
because you know he had already been
with her
and I was like wait but you gave your
sister her number his number right and
then did she reach out to him she was
like okay yeah so she reached out yeah
okay
it wasn't like he he called it off with
him then he went after your sister like
you ended things right she was
interested you gave her the number and
green lit the situation and then you
didn't like it after and I was a bit
like after asking these questions I was
like she painted it kind of one way yeah
when I actually found out I was like
yeah yeah yeah it was completely yeah
did you see how I decided to sit my tea
at one point I decided to I'm just
listening you know
more believable if she wasn't like the
fact that she got so mad because if
someone said something about you that's
like how did my teeth come into the
conversation
you might find it annoying right and so
you might be like okay like what up but
if you're getting like angry at
insulting people I'm just like well like
yeah but you know from what she
described earlier I wouldn't be
surprised if you said if I'm a childhood
of arguing my brothers I'd have to lie
every now and again if I'm a child with
arguments that I feel like you know like
I I like in general I think once someone
has that defense that's so thick so
thick there's nothing you can like you
can't actually truly trust the story
that comes out of their mouth basically
being rude is it just sort of illustrate
what Pearl's been saying though about
like not taking that accountability yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but there's not taking accountability
there's there's like in this I'm seeing
a mixture of about three types of things
in one no but then it's like it was
pretty toxic
relationship you don't get that you
don't get that toxic without getting
trauma in a relationship too
I'm sorry like you cannot it takes two
to tangle I want yeah I will not deal
with this like narrative that oh it's
only him that's toxic toxic [__] she
just got toxic right here but when you
think when you think about it you're
supposed to listen to your man right so
like you're supposed like you're not
supposed to argue with it hey Paul can I
ask a question as well didn't she say
that because I don't believe that as
well early one woman she was speaking
about her boyfriend uh about oh yeah it
was three years ago then we found out
it's a whole different X now
yeah how many exes were there
she was like she was like 22. yeah she
said oh 18 I was with him for you I was
like three years and then now you're 26.
it could be it could be a thing she was
like she could they could have broken up
when she was like well she said two and
a half she said she said it like in one
line she didn't mention she didn't say
oh that was that X by the way this other
X she literally just said oh yeah and
when I was 73 uh your experience what
does that mean when women are like Miss
whatever the ACT oh like what is that
well when they miss their ex no no when
they're like the details of the timeline
oh they're off like what and you're like
in your experience what does that
typically mean well
yeah
but I'm asking like why okay so okay
it's very simple okay first okay for
here's a couple red flags I picked up
number one she's a woman no I'm just
joking
[Laughter]
all right based
red flag number two that I picked up was
when I asked her are you a virgin she
was like
yes
and it's not facial dude she's looking
like this is the pause and then number
three okay you don't have to sit there
and think and remember about the truth
you know the truth just comes up you're
like oh yeah it's just that that was
that right and so when she had to sit
back and like remember the truth I was
just like oh I don't know and then the
inconsistencies and the stories and then
kit with the KO punch was like wait a
minute because what we were talking
about after this and she was like [__]
you and your actor reward [__]
I think when I met her she said my suit
was nice on the balcony didn't she like
she said something she said something
about my suit in the balcony she was
like yeah the suit was nice and then now
she's always coming into this I'm just
curious
and your experience like what are they
hiding like what is the some sort of
some sort of treachery and deception
that she because she women are smart
enough to know
how they're perceived yeah and they're
definitely under they're definitely know
when the camera's on them or they're
being interrogated by somebody and they
there's an authority over them so she's
like oh wait oh I'm definitely a virgin
yeah and uh did you notice how as well
though she said oh we shouldn't be
talking about this because I thought you
know your second point I thought that
the reason she paused was because she
didn't she felt uncomfortable with
revealing like talking about her
sexuality like that on a public forum
but then she then said oh yes I'm a
virgin but we should be talking about
this yeah yeah she was trying to get it
off yeah yeah that's what they'll do
they'll bring up a situation and when
you ask the questions they don't like
then they don't want to talk about it
but they always bring it up first always
but then that leads on to like what
we're talking about with how a lot of
men will leave their actions a lot of
females will leave with their emotions I
really think that what I saw earlier on
was a gigantic emotional response and a
defense mechanism along with a lot a lot
of emotions mixed in because because
well and the girl that came on that I
actually like believe was a virgin you
know like she was good
no she was great she was on um yeah yeah
you believe it right yeah was it the one
who wore glasses were a mask because she
didn't want to be upset
believe she's a virgin
no she was just really she was really um
I think she was on fresh and fit once
too uh yeah she was on fresh and fit one
she went super viral on there no she was
just a sweetheart like she was just so
sweet
um she wasn't defensive at all and she
wouldn't go around like I think she was
kind of like she didn't even want to say
that she was a virgin do you know what I
mean like she wanted to try to put it
out there like that and then what like
isn't that the ultimate Flex so like
yeah I am a virgin like why would you be
hesitant to release that information but
I mean all of us here we're obviously
we're all non-virgins right we're all
war no I just can't you're definitely
not virgin
[Laughter]
I decided I'm born again now you're born
again she got mad when I said that I was
like are you a born-again virgin she's
like don't [__] tell that [__] to me
yeah I'm a proud born again
I just bought it off of eBay
I love the way your MLD suit always
comes into this though so like yeah
all of my suits are Loro piano you know
think about it all bro like when a
woman's arguing with you they'll try to
get you where it hurts didn't I say that
earlier I said that earlier she's like
when you're when you're logically making
a point she's like yeah well that's why
you have fake teeth and you're still
sucking [__] sucks
he loves it oh
and you don't get triggered by
you know like lies into you you get
triggered by when somebody hits the
truth if she said that her body count
was full I wouldn't care no one else
would eat no no I think I think I think
it's because and I'm not saying this is
what she was lying about but I think
it's because as a Muslim or someone who
works right Muslim and this is a public
forum right yeah yeah there is a level
of appearance and reputation yeah over
over in age people
You're Expecting even if she whatever
religion you're what you're expecting
she's a virgin yeah and then another and
I wanted to tell her too like for me
personally like if a girl has Snapchat
that's a [__] red flag
that's just a red flag like what are you
doing for me personally like you're just
on a platform that deletes all evidence
it's like are you kidding me like and
then no like come on you're right and
like you're not even a social media is
she an influencer she have a big Channel
she's doing something she didn't she
didn't say that she is I'm youtubing and
trying to get back into it and like you
know she said she's saying she's
starting up like you know she's good
she's got a platform
I just I'm to the point I've been doing
these shows for so long yeah if I tell
you something once and you don't listen
I'm just I'm not dealing with it
we got five likes left to open the chat
yeah five legs left open the chat I have
super chats though um I'm trying to pull
them up I forgot to pull them up I
really want to vote with the chat I want
Chad to ask us I want to ask Chad if
they think she's a virgin or not once we
open a chat
um okay supers
I think that whole thing's a
contradiction to some degree though like
in inject not even her and folks and I'm
saying being a muslim okay let's say I'm
not saying that she's for fat not a
virgin but let's say that she's not a
virgin and she also has to maintain a
certain image to society don't you see
some type of you're taking the pissed
but don't you see don't you see how
that's like isn't that like some type of
like is there nothing wrong with that
like what so I'm in a Muslim Society now
and I'm not a virgin I'm I have to
appear this way but I want to live this
way
it is yeah and then yeah yeah no no not
actually what it what it is I'm saying
in regards to that if imagine a girl who
for example let's say she has a heavily
promiscuous past yeah then she meets a
guy let's say who he doesn't because he
doesn't move in the streets like that
he's a very good guy let's say he's from
a Muslim background right he's only ever
been with maybe one or two girls yeah
right she doesn't have to tell him about
her us and if she can avoid him finding
out about that as a virgin she's as good
as a virgin because he will take her as
a wife etc etc right and this is
something that definitely you know girls
have taught me of their friends where
they'd been with over 50 to 100 guys
than a guy they met who was a really
good guy only been with one or two
people good guys sound religious
background right he he's none the wiser
and now they're married happily married
Etc so obviously her disclosing any kind
of information right to the Future man
if he stumbled upon this channel
what the [__] is this yeah no Hyman no
diamond yeah
which is which is which is all fair
enough but I mean you you've got a sort
of thing if you're going on a podcast
where you're going to be talking about
dating and you're gonna get asked about
your body yeah that's what I don't I'm
pretty things like like don't say that
this is entirely dating board this is a
very common topic on this show it's a
bit like when straighter right you know
that girl straight or I got thrown off
the whatever podcast one of the deaths
of these girls uh you know
no I think it was a different one but
she got thrown off because they are
asking her if she was a virgin and she
wouldn't answer the question and then in
the end they threw off the podcast and
it's people were saying well the thing
is like you knew you were coming onto a
dating podcast yeah you knew you were
probably gonna get asked that yeah it's
like it's not asking your body care
that's okay
[Music]
come on 26. I'm 23.
the whole the I mean all of the symptoms
she was emitting were not one of a
Georgian virgin women are like very koi
naive like very Purity yeah they're pure
they're very they're very nice they
haven't been jaded yet
I was sensing the trauma of past
relationships yeah or watching Express
like I I really pay attention to
people's body language and so forth and
within that wasn't just oh how dare you
it's wait you're trying to tell everyone
that's the energy
wait there yo right now I mean when she
was speaking to you that was one but it
was more specific with him as well I
have this effect on women but it was
even it was even when I was like you
don't I was like she's like do you
remember our conversation yeah uh parts
of it it's like uh it was one hour ago
like how did you not why do you remember
the parts of it but I think this is
important for guys to see because it's
like a lot of guys will will hear hear
this and believe it
as you think well I'm not talking about
I mean I mean like in the church this is
where I see it because that's what
happens
yeah so you go to the church they
Rebrand and get them a virgin guy who
doesn't know any better yeah like that
that's what I'm saying like not hey guys
guys with like five minutes of
experience can pick this stuff out like
guy that dude yeah well listen I I've
been with them everything as well we
have all been with a decent amount of
women here on this panel and honestly
I'm sorry that I I don't think I don't
think that girl's virgin or she has just
been through a shitload of trauma that
made her that insufferable no I'm sorry
I'm
I don't think he's a virgin like yeah
Troy uh if I had to bet no I don't think
she is but I'll tell you one thing so
what you were saying about like if
there's gaps in the story like she had
what would that mean yeah and my view on
that is firstly I I don't know for sure
what it means but it will be a major
major red flag if I was dealing with a
woman and she was coming with those
inconsistencies of like oh yeah well
maybe I was dating him oh no he's when I
was 23 no when I was 18. yeah all of
that kind of stuff yeah I think I think
guys will accept more than like the
public like I think guys except a lot
[Music]
and get your dating coach as well for
women right the backbone of all
relationships romantic friendships
business relationships is trust and then
the moment you start lying or even if
you're dumb and you make a mistake but
you start projecting these
inconsistencies within your truth that's
when you get people start being like
wait a minute like what do you mean I
think it has a lot to do with your
Marvels as well because you're literally
saying oh I'm not gonna tell you this
part because I think it's bad so if you
think it's better and you think if you
told me this it's gonna make me be
repulsed or make me not want to be with
you then you are the embodiment of what
I don't want to be exactly yeah but I
think I think I think like you said a
learning point for guys watching is that
if if you're dealing with a girl and
she's coming in with these like weird
inconsistencies or it doesn't quite add
up um that's definitely yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then and then also when the
attacks start coming when you start when
you start prying for the truth it's like
well you know what you have your [__]
suits
people stop the cat yeah
feminine way we probably would have left
her alone if she just you know I just
really would rather not talk about this
like yeah probably would have just moved
on but when you're like
she's being attacked by men yeah she
should be like I want every man's
attacking me right now I'm just like
yeah because you mentioned men a few
times when she was going back against
you guys she goes I'm not gonna be
supposed to be like that by a man or did
you see when she'd say a few remarks
that was to do with oh because you're a
man you can't say that listen listen so
probably got a thousand likes can we
open it open the chat we can't we can I
want to ask the chat I want to do the
Virgin poll to the chat oh oh no no no
no no okay no no no okay now let's let's
this is forget the Virgin poll do you
think she was lying or do you think she
was telling the truth so if you think
she was lying put a one in the chat and
you think she was telling the truth put
a two in the chat that's what I wanted I
just wanted to see what the people have
to say for every other number if you
think she was lying
I want to see how many other numbers go
against one
I wanted to guess her body count in the
chat
I even say I even say this to like my
female clients you know yeah in the
sense of like don't you don't lie about
your past because yes if you're with a
guy and chances are he's going to be
your level of intelligence or higher
because most women that's what they like
to choose yeah there's going to be a
point throughout the relationship right
if he's with his wherewithal which he
likely is in comparison to you but
you're going to say something that's
inconsistent to what you've told him
previously right and when that happens
you've already that plants the seed for
distrust because then when he starts in
quite like hold on you've told me two
different stories
can't you and I you and I are going to
be best friends let me tell you why let
me tell you what the last last girl
dated I dated disco for two years okay
and when I first met her she lied about
her past and she lied about her body
count she lied about her Purity and she
tricked me and when I because you know
what
the only thing that keeps lies going are
more lives boom right and eventually the
truth came out and the truth came out
and bro when I found out the truth I was
so disgusted and I wasn't disgusted when
the fact that she did what she did in
the past but I was so disgusted that she
thought I was dumb enough to believe her
[__] lies and and and and the insult
of my intelligence like how dare you
[__] how dare you [__] think I am as
dumb as you do you think you could just
lie and trick me and he's right he's a
thousand percent right and that goes for
men too anybody don't enter a
relationship and start lying yeah okay
it's weak be a thou if you're a scumbag
just Own It Be scumbag just be like all
right I'm just you know I'm in scumbag
you know but the when you the thing is
when you lie and a lot of girls are
ashamed of their past and it is what it
is but men will respect you a thousand
percent times more like listen I don't
talk about it but listen I'm just going
to tell you I have been through some
[__] it isn't what it is I just want you
to love me for me at least from that
moment forward I know what I'm dealing
with yes and then I know how to move
forward appropriately because I I
started dating or I'm not really dating
I'm seeing this other girl she's
beautiful right in our first date she
was like well you know
[__] happened and you know I kind of
went through whole phase I was like okay
cool I respect the fact that you're
telling me that you went through this
whole face yeah and now when I deal with
her I'm like okay like she may be Helen
she may not be but at least I know
moving forward like that X Factor of hoe
phase is there for me to calculate into
the entire situation yeah but what if
she would have been like no virgin girl
and blah blah blah blah and then you
march down the path of relationship you
waste your time and then and then you
find out later that oh wait
you've lied to me and you actually have
like a [__] 50 plus body count you
the guy really is disgusted because he's
disgusted from the from the fact that
you manipulated me you lied to me
because I you know just be real you know
what I mean
would you have dated her still if if she
was honest from the jump if she was
honest from the jump
um she was she was a great girl in that
sense but it was just the the the fact
that I found out like a a year later
right no because I'm asking like would
she would she have gotten a better
outcome if she didn't lie well the thing
is this I was in love with a fake person
and then when I found out the truth I
started to like fall out of love with
her because I started seeing the real
her and the biggest thing that made me
upset was that
I just felt so gross that she she lied
and she tricked me and I just I feel
like I fell in love with a fake person
so that built up a lot of resentment
what would you say is worse a woman that
says her body counts 15 and lies about
it or a woman that says her body counts
20 and tells you the truth truth every
time oh the truth yeah exactly the kids
saying truth every time you know I think
you know you know I think it's a factor
yeah I think with regards to women and
men yeah we can all women can say oh I
want a guy that's you know six six
figures uh strong masculine guys didn't
be like I want a woman that's feminine
but I do believe that some areas you can
increase the percentage enough yeah that
some other areas don't become as
important what you know let's say for
example yeah I think if a woman's
femininity yeah and a woman's honesty
and a woman's like roles of how to be a
good wife or a good girlfriend or
something oh just off the charts all the
time I really think there's plenty of
guys not most but plenty of guys that
would be like you know what yeah
I'll add on to that I I recently met a
girl in Miami when I was on one of these
podcasts and we had just gotten into the
conversation talking about x's and
pastors because she knows what I do for
living and she we talked about whatever
and she was very open with me and like
you know it was like some people would
consider it a highbot account but she
was also stunningly gorgeous honest with
me successful like successful I don't
care about a woman's money and [__] but
the fact that she was successful lets me
know that she has a [__] brain yeah
and she was physically fit and she was
just such I think she's so gorgeous and
like a great communicator I was just
like damn bro I like [__] like this
girl you know what I mean like you can
Overlook that [__] but the thing is the
number one thing guys look for in a
relationship I think women look for this
too is somebody you can trust yeah
somebody you can call if there's trouble
out there and then if you if thing is
this because it's not about sex it's not
about looks it's not about money it's
all that it's about damn like if the
[__] goes down yeah your woman is number
two in your life like like she like your
your business your calls your duties
number one and number two is the woman
like can I rely on you can I call you at
three o'clock in the morning if I've
been falsely accused and I need bail
money you know what I mean you know I'll
tell you what John as well like I think
and tell me what you think but you know
you said about when when the girls lied
to you about her sexual parts that less
that level of disgust right yeah I think
a massive part of that is because a
man's worst fear of raising kids that
aren't his yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
right raising a child that isn't his so
and at the time that that would happen
is when a woman lies about her sexual
past because she says you're the father
and you're actually not the father no
that's the rule
underpinning isn't it yeah yeah I think
that's one of the elements of it though
I think there's there's like there's
that as well that yo father but I think
there's that
there's just that I have the element of
weight there so let me get it straight
here you with your chest were willing to
say oh wait there he hasn't clapped on
yet yeah
so how long can I play this game for
because you have to remember that
there's a difference between if a woman
likes you for two seconds like let's say
what happened there that's okay she lied
to us but we're not gonna fall like
idiots but then let's say that we go
three years it's not just about if she
tells you the truth at the end of the
theater you have to think what else did
she lie about what else is there and
then it becomes a game and she sustained
that character throughout the street it
becomes a thing of like it becomes a
thing of like your own imagination is
the measurement because at least okay
cool let's say you say to someone this
girl's got a body count of 30. a lot
quite a lot of people could be like oh
wait there that's too high
um others could be like you know what
yeah that's fine for me I'm calling that
number yeah but when it's a game of
imagination yes when you can't that's
now a thing of my number is 70. so I'm
thinking it could be 70. no and then
that's that's what happened to me so
then in addition to that after I found
out the truth through a number of
inconsistent disease because I'm [__]
smart like I made a multi-million dollar
business like I'm not lying from a hoe I
could figure that [__] out yeah like so
you know I I how did it take a year then
dude I'm not gonna lie because I was too
busy I was just too busy that was the
time I was dating three girls
five but I was only taking three
seriously but you know that that that
life
my life was a whole face
[Laughter]
but no I want to add on to that real
quick it's just that when when you spot
that one lie then the relationship is
Tainted because she's like she's like oh
you know I gotta work like like she's
sucking some dick you know I mean even
though she does have to work late and it
just [__] with your head but on both
sides too for the men do men don't
mention life women shouldn't lie because
it [__] with your head and you're just
like you can't even focus on the person
in front of you you can focus on your
duty your business your Fitness whatever
this case may be yeah you're even in the
relationship with that because she's
gonna start to say you have to remember
that a woman's emotions play Vital
factors towards the the overall the
reality yeah overall the relationship so
it's like if she's seeing that you're
disgusted in her yeah that's gonna play
a role yeah if she's seeing that oh wait
you don't want to touch me no more you
don't want to hold me you don't want to
be intimate with me in any type of way
that now is going to affect what she now
does and you see some females here are
insecurity could just be like okay I
need to feel love right now let me just
go back to my ex yeah I need to feel
like I need to go let me let me see and
most women cheat with an ax yeah so yeah
so that's that's is there is that can I
just like one other thing is there is
there the possibility that like it's
more about not lying than it is about
how much you reveal yes because because
it's not like we're giving the
impression like on the first or second
day you're gonna be sitting down going
right well my body count is yeah 100
yeah like we I I wouldn't expect her and
I wouldn't ask exactly yeah yeah I
wouldn't even you know what is your what
is your number what's your body like I
wouldn't get into that conversation
however what you want to avoid is
somebody who's actively lying about it
you know you mean a woman and she's like
oh yeah you know because yeah your trust
is damaged the backbone of all
relationships friendships business love
it is all trust and the number one way
to damage trust is with a lie and you
know you know when you said revealing
yeah like for example I feel like we're
all the same way we're on the face first
date we'd never say to a woman first
thing wash your body count yeah I think
that would all say however in regards to
revealing things we are we're all
intelligent male's females we're all
intelligent creatures I am going to be
able to see what you're not saying I'm
gonna be able to see what you're not
putting forward I'm gonna be able to see
when you're kind of skipping around we
were able to do it with her within the
space of two two minutes yeah so it's
like in a relationship over the space of
a year I'm gonna like why didn't you
tell me that you you did do a gangbang
why why
you're still friends with your ex and I
had to find out because I saw a
notification probably on your phone why
did like why did you tell me about the
bukoki party
I feel like I feel like a woman not
saying something is as bad as them
saying something if it is a lie I'm
trying it's called Lying by a mission
isn't it I'm trying to find the stat but
it's like I think 50 of men will ask
your body count wow I just don't think
you should ask I personally yeah I don't
know because I'm saying we all wanna
know
don't get into City we all want to know
but we're not all one I would know I
wouldn't ask I don't ask well you know
you don't want to say kid wanted to ask
a question to the panel well it kind of
[__] yes but I wanted to ask what do you
think is something men lie about in the
beginning what's the equivalent that men
would like
I'll tell you a story I'll tell you a
story of a guy that came on the show you
know he was talking about um his
business right and then um he was like
saying he makes six figures from it and
like I was like oh cool like I just I'm
just like I just believe people but I
have a producers that maybe sense cap
more than more than I do yeah we looked
up the business it was dissolved oh [__]
I would say we looked at that business I
would say I think the majority guy's a
lot well they I think they insinuate
about sexual performance
oh girl I'm gonna [__] the [__] out of
you not like that but I think they like
that's it they guessed it I don't know
what because I don't like I'm so
successful now like I'm so terrified
when I go on these new dates yeah I lead
with all my shitty points yeah I'm like
I have anger problems
I should do that I'll be like I'll go
through your phone
like most commonly in society though I
think most men lie about their intention
of it because we're talking about first
ah yeah yeah yeah
we're not talking yeah yeah the first
intention the reason why is because all
of us as men let us be honest anytime
you see a female you're attracted to
that you would you want you want to have
sex with her no don't get twisted you
can have you can have sexual restraint
or you could be in a relationship where
you don't even desire anyone else
anymore but I'm talking about you first
see the woman that you actually like
there's going to be a sexual arousal to
some degree like to some degree at least
you may also be stimulated by her mental
her mentally so and so forth but there's
a oh
if she said would you like to have sex
right now and she's the girl that I like
would I say no to that not a lot of men
would say no but the thing is that if
you go to a first date and a woman says
what is your intention with me now you
three are dating coaches right you've
gone you've been a many many many many
days are you telling me that everything
are you trying to get the British
constitution because I need this fifth
so you guys you guys have been on many
many dates yeah so you're telling me
that let's say you've dated 50 between
all of you guys you're telling me each
time you wanted to know about her
mentality
I'll be honest thing you got somebody
with that straight away I'll be honest
with you I used to be if a girl was
attractive if she was hot I was like
yeah I would but hold on
but I think when you've got when you've
had enough experience with women to a
certain degree you realize even if it's
just a casual thing you are still
spending time with them yeah you are
still investing I agree yeah so even if
I'm even if I was only in a place where
I'm looking for something casual it's
still important to me to like who she is
as a person I'm making though is that
it's not that I'm coming from a casual
perspective I'm coming from a first
intrusive thought of when you see them
the first thought of it because you have
to remember yeah from a prime you don't
know if you want something serious
because you don't no no no no exactly
but you're still attracted so because
you're still attracted you're going to
have the the thing that's great that's
that's the fuel that's making you
gravitate towards so what's the what's
the question I'm saying here that like
what's the most common thing that guys
will lie about on their first date now
the intention could be I think it is
intention
around she's like oh yeah I'm looking
for a relationship
just be so honest whenever okay cool
pornography sites these these talk to
these women so forth you really think
that they're not going it without with a
sexual not motive but a sexual fueling
beforehand before they even get to that
scenario can I respond to that I think
there's something I think there's two
points here yeah I think one I think
you're right I think I think they do lie
or or rather per pass by a mission yeah
about intention but but having having
said that I I never get into the
conversation on the first day and I
would advise anything yes I agree as
well not to get into the conversation
yeah so what are your intentions yeah I
hate I hate when they ask that okay
it's too transactional it's it's a very
normally way of going about
I was offered marriage recently on a
first day
[Applause]
yeah
buddy yeah I wouldn't recommend guys do
that though
was he Muslim no no no yeah no she's
touching the head you know
yeah I just I thought it was gonna be
like a normal date and then it was yeah
he was like ready to get married oh wow
he's seen your uh he's seen you all
right yeah it's red kneading skills
okay now do you know what's weird
um it's like weird going on a date with
someone that knows everything about you
yeah
okay I wouldn't be bad if it could be
equal we use a YouTube fan no yeah no no
because imagine imagine okay if you go
on a date with me but I can also look up
everything about you online then it's
equal then it's equal we're on equal
Playing Fields but when I'm like telling
a story and I'm like oh he's heard this
on my phone
definitely I'd say I'd say intention
what you say intention but okay Troy
what do you think no I think he's right
I think what do you think yeah intention
for sure yeah I would say sexual
performance slash intention but after
you said intention I was like no no
because I've lied about intention plenty
of times I think it's yeah no you're 100
but it's about how it's conveyed because
what I I tend to like finesse it a bit
on these days so I'm not sitting down on
the day and I'm not saying so tell me
what are your you know where do you see
yourself in five years time and all of
that because that is a bit normally it's
a little bit it's it's not very sexy you
know you want to keep your cards close
to your church you want to hold some
things back and stuff however can I say
hand on heart that I haven't been into
date situations and given the impression
that maybe I'm looking for a little bit
more than perhaps I am you know I can't
I can't say that okay guys I need to
read super chats
okay guys guys 20 bucks and up we read
so uh Zoo nush something she was lying
they also believed that yeah
hey some of these I don't know the
conversion so you might just get lucky
rambe I'm somalis don't move like that
we don't claim her
inconsistent story is starting to get
defensive personal attack she seems like
a narcissist I questioned her motives uh
being on the show
um all right rhombe
um Somali lost in London tell her needs
to do what's back in Alice I don't know
what that is
um oh you know what that I don't I don't
know what that means uh L3 prank um he
insulted Hindu for views oh I think did
Andrew tayden salt and do for views I
don't I don't know anything about that I
think L3 means a h3h3
yeah whatever
um reaction channels are the epitome of
amateur commentators criticizing
Christian Ronaldo their spectators not
players they've just never tasted the
sand of the Arena shout out to John MLD
for changing lives
and then let me refresh it really quick
to make sure I don't miss any uh no
that's it okay well David Bond is
watching guys I got a question for all
three of you how do you think life would
win if you honest people intentions join
dating all the time all right terrible I
am
genuinely be a virgin though you guys
honest actually we had a conversation
yeah uh like
we talked about uh we talked about about
you know mango and kind of yeah physical
escapades I'm straight up with that
and I've had girls accept that but but
have you always been straight up you've
been a liar before I'm not saying
sometimes I'm saying 100 from Child I'm
talking about before you could even
become the person you are now with the
experience you have now I'm saying from
birth you've always been honest about
dating from the get-go yo
no
but I don't think it's a realistic
question because I don't think anybody
but that's a good that's a good thing
that's a good question for the reason
why I'm saying it you don't lie anymore
yeah right that's right
okay cool cool okay you can still have
the same game that you've got you can
still have the same type of you can
still make a woman feel nice when you're
speaking to them all you have to do is
just be honest in every single day I'll
answer that I'll answer I think that if
I were to have been more honest about
everything from the get-go I think I
would be way more confident than I am
now you think yeah because the thing is
this right at one when I was dating
those three main girls and I was
juggling five yeah and I was directly
honest with all them
well I would like go to bed and I'm like
damn I'm a [__] man like these
[__] know the truth and they keep
coming back for more
but the thing is it is a short-lived
Victory because eventually because every
girl nowadays right they just think so
highly of themselves and they their ego
can't handle the fact of truth and
reality when
that one girl is not good enough for you
as in man you know I think that really
messes with them I think it's very
difficult to be entirely honest because
as a guy I think maybe it's a woman as
well I think as a guy you know we are
programmed to one variety yeah right and
to have that conversation with somebody
that you're in love with and she's
deeply in love with you he's a very
difficult conversation to have to sit
down and say oh babe this is so perfect
look at the sunset oh such a beautiful
evening over London you know what you
know I kind of fancy other girls if
another if another surely walk past now
I probably should probably would so I
think this is what I've said and from
the get-go in the sense of okay that you
are who I am truly investing in yeah who
I'm taking seriously right and that this
isn't saying that I am definitely going
to go out there be like trying to have
such different girls
but it but it may happen where I do that
now if that's not for you that's okay we
don't have to get into this but then
leave it I say it's up to you I think
yeah no that's that's a good way of
doing it I think that sort of monogamous
relationships though there's a sort of
almost like a shared fantasy that both
parties enter into of like that's true I
don't look at anybody else and she's
like I don't look at anybody else yeah
and it's this kind of shared fantasy
which everyone sort of intellectually
knows is not true right but you have to
sort of pretend in order to to maintain
the status quo right right pretty sure
for sure I think I I don't know I I
think I might have to sit down with my
girl I don't want to say well
well okay it's like for example so like
that you know my girl now right we went
to see which one now stop it
we gotta give him another actor over the
years
[Laughter]
and guys remember I said I will sip in
my teeth
but his phone's blown up right now
we went to watch Chris Brown right we
wanted to watch Chris Brown and like
obviously Chris Brown pulls girls on
stage all the time right and I'll be
honest this sounds cringe as [__] that's
I know she's amazing I was like look
babe if you if he pulls you up that's
Chris Brown like cool do you think I get
it whatever right and she was like babe
I would never do that to you that's a
good girl that's a good girl I wouldn't
want to do that anyway even though he's
like my favorite artist that's a good
girl
things like that that's a salad even if
let's say notice but let's say her body
count was 25 or something mad let's say
you're so close not even close but I'm
saying let's pretend yeah just hearing
that element there of her saying but
babes I wouldn't even go on stage
because I respect you a man values that
up here yeah yeah yeah absolutely a lot
of women aren't taught this they keep
thinking that oh wait okay big breasts
big ass look innocent that's what and
and and if anything outside of that yeah
they'll attack you for it and it's like
if they really understood the diameters
of how deep it is I don't think the goal
for certain lies
what are you what are you showing over
sorry his girl's texting him how sexy he
is
from the event we just went to right she
sent me these photos and I was like B
why are you so pretty she was like
because I have a sexy man next to me
good man lucky maybe I should stop this
guys
men have emotions too you have to
understand that to some degree yeah like
it's not even about let's make this it's
about sometimes you just want to feel
nice as well you know and that respect
is how I translate you are making me
feel nice respect his love for me
respect is my type of that's like when
you give me respect to you I'm just like
that appeals to my emotions you know
that makes me feel positive happy door
for me kicks in my head because I'm not
to myself yo you respect to me it makes
me thought I've got a solid team to Take
On The World but exactly not respect to
me it's me versus you and the world bro
and boom and that's why that's why these
girls they'll date a guy and he'll date
him for like three four five years
but he'll never put a ring on her finger
yeah but then he dates another girl and
he dates one to two years and boom he
marries you know you know why why
because she gives him peace of mind
I'm sorry I'm sorry
you know I don't have to worry about her
what her hoe ass friends texting her was
she posting some [__] Haram ass [__]
on her Instagram like a man a man every
day has to wake up and it doesn't matter
if you're in the middle class top of the
line whatever the case may be every man
every day a man has to wake up and fight
the world and the last thing he wants to
fight is some ungrateful [__] in his
life he doesn't want to fight with that
girl and a lot of guys they [__] have
to make a deal with the devil and kind
of get with girls that aren't
necessarily checking all boxes I think
that fight can be worse than than any
other fight really no no it's it's the
worst thing and a lot of guys settle
because they don't have the they don't
have the abundance mindset to think that
they can get out there and get better or
or get a woman of quality but yeah
that's what that that's a big thing that
a lot of women don't understand if you
can bring your man peace of mind it's
and especially
No Hoe [__] like Peace of Mind of you
not going out there hoeing around like I
need to go on this girls trip I need to
go to the club with this I need to
[__] up update my SnapChat or any
[__] like guys don't want to deal like
when a guy loves you the last thing he
wants to do is imagine some dude banging
you and if you're giving off all these
symptoms of of whole [__] like I know
like modern culture we're supposed to
say well you shouldn't do that you
should respect the woman within a
Snapchat and all that but
an ideal situation A guy doesn't want to
have to put up with that [__] that's
right that's why when you have a girl
that brings you peace of mind and it is
not a drip of whole [__] activity
around her he will give her the entire
world you know he'll give her and that's
why these girls like they'll they'll
date because the guy will date you and
put up with them for like a couple years
but then he dumps them and then he finds
another girl who gives him that peace of
mind to you it's over do you feel like
when men are ready to get married they
don't waste a lot of time yeah it yes
but it it absolutely depends on the
woman yes it absolutely depends you know
like like him like his girlfriend
texting him right now like I would never
go on stage Chris Brown and you're such
a sexy man and stuff like
that right there that that's why he won
the [__] Australia best actor award
because he got a great woman at home
supporting him that's a big part of it
like oh you man man listen you know what
like for example you know who's a great
woman in this world I don't know if you
guys know who she is you guys know who D
Devlin is no D Devlin is Conor
McGregor's uh wife and she had supported
Conor McGregor from day one yeah and he
she he was on welfare and she was
working full-time to help that man out
and you can see when you watch these
interviews with him that woman is like
blindly loyal to McGregor in a great way
and because and he says it all time if I
didn't have this great woman with me
there is no way I would have been able
to ascend some Such Great Heights and
I'm not trying to like simp for women
but the reality is it's very very very
very very true when you have when you're
a man and you have a good woman by her
side that does not give you stress and
she makes you feel safe and she knows
you like The World is Yours there's no
treachery yeah you know what I mean
that's why these guys conquer and then
the other side of the coin is when you
have a treacherous [__] in your life
and you've seen great men fall in from
these Great Heights because they got
some [__] hell in the house with them
with a ring on her finger and she thinks
she knows some [__] and that's how you
see these guys well it's not even
necessarily treacherous it's just if she
is not supportive of you and your goals
that's treachery in my book yeah
I've noticed it seems like just from
what I've seen um guys it's like when
they're ready to get married it's kind
of like that's like they're like a guy
once he's got his money figured out
he'll kind of look at the girl next to
him and be like is it her yes or no then
dump her if it's a no and then he's like
on a mission to find the girl he's like
married absolutely when a guy when a guy
really wants to get married he he does
like in his mind because you do like you
know I'm kind of at that phase now like
I have made all the money I've slept
with all the girls and now I'm like I'm
looking for
the one like the not like saying like my
soul mate or the one that I that I can
trust bring it to my life and have
children with right and when you're on
that path like you're very vicious in
the sense like okay like one red flag
you're out yeah exactly no no time to
waste you know I'm out like you're you
did this no you're not you hate men no
you have blue hair your feminist no
you're done you know I mean and like
when you're in that mode too because I
I'll tell you this too and I don't know
if this is just subjective to me only
but I feel like my like biological clock
taking like I I see kids like I want
children I want a son yeah and I I feel
it I like I feel that I want a son
you're 37 37 yeah so this is what I feel
like so you at 37 now you're on a
mission you're looking for a wife yeah
because if if I were to get because what
what Tate was saying is two is so true
like what am I gonna do like go out
there and just keep [__] hoes and
keep like doing the same thing I already
am bored I think if a girl met you at
right do you think that she could have
gotten you to marry her at 30. no
because I was too stupid yeah but that's
that's what I I feel like sometimes
girls will get bitter because they might
date a guy that's like
at the wrong time yes and some girls
some girls can wait it out like if she
met you at 30 and then at 37 like you
look oh you look you're ready to do that
oh she's there yeah no no I definitely
agree with you yeah um but like it just
it you know it just it's a timing thing
too is it really it and it's timing
based upon maturity and I think some
guys
they never mature too there's there's
some guys like everybody like I think
the world needs to realize like not
everybody gets a happy ending um
happy ending do you think
gigantic fear actor that
as a man I'm putting myself on the line
if I get married right now true like in
England England especially it's horrible
here because in England I'm not sure how
the the prenup thing works exactly it
doesn't exist here it doesn't exist
together
so it is yeah so so I checked and they
are actually things they also they also
incentivize abuse allegations here
because they give you a free lawyer if
she accuses you of abuse yeah yeah it's
really I'm doing a documentary on
divorce right now okay I didn't know
that before I'm sorry I'm curious what
you don't want to be married I can't
remember if you said you want to be
married I wouldn't legally no I was I
was talking about I'm gonna ask you next
though don't worry oh [__] me me
personally me um I I never say never but
getting legally married certainly is not
high on the agenda no no do you want
like kids and stuff again I'd never say
never but I wasn't I was never the most
paternal of people because I think
because my family background was a bit
screwed up and whatever so I think I
think there's been some some stuff but
um so so yeah that's kind of where I'm
sitting at it at the moment I'm just
okay so this question doesn't really
apply so I'm just curious because 37 now
you're looking for a wife I'm curious
one's the ideal age for you you don't
marriage isn't high on the priority so
what was the ideal age that you wanted
to get married at me yeah you
uh if I'm being honest I think the
earliest I would look at would be like
35. how old are you I'm 29. oh okay okay
okay okay yeah okay so 35 is the ideal
age for you what about you you're you're
33 yeah I say that for me with absolute
honesty I don't know when I'm ready when
when I plan to be ready to be married
only because it's like what I was saying
earlier on a lot of the what I'll look
for in marriage is to do heavily with
the person as well growing into that
marriage as well because like I could
say to myself I'm ready for marriage
year but if I don't feel this person is
ready for marriage or were compatible
fully or or so like not fully but like
if like like it has to do a lot with
how's the relationship has grown into
that marriage too as well and that's a
difficult thing to predict it's hard to
say like any like everyone has ever
gotten with an ex before thought it was
going to last forever everyone has got
button things it didn't it's statistics
it's just probability happens no I think
it's just more like Wendy's like what
stage do you think you'd be like I'm
ready to build a family I'd say but this
is the thing I could probably be at that
stage right now would not know it like
in my things really to do like how my
relationship is here and how we're
developing into coming into those stages
because it's me also looking at how
another human being is moving I'm not
completely judging this off of my
standards so it's based on the
relationship you're in yeah yeah
especially the relationship and it's
really based off of like how things like
develop like it's not say that like I'm
not saying that oh we won't get married
and say that I'm literally I felt like
I'm watching the process and it's like I
feel like oh that you see like how you
are a stage of absolute certainty yeah I
think that will just kick in for me when
when we get to that stage and I can just
be like you know what now when we're
married but that could probably be
tomorrow it could be two years from now
it could be five it could be I don't I
don't want to say an answer and like you
know yeah yeah
it's interesting how the age for
marriage has sort of moved moved back so
much like because you're like 23 my dad
was 24 when he had me
and it was normal back then yeah exactly
exactly because they just they did they
just have you on this consumerism
Hedonism [__] because like I thought
like when you get rich like you're just
gonna be always happy shopping at Louis
Vuitton and going to these like high-end
restaurants and stuff Dan Bilzerian
talks about it like Dan Bilzerian said
back in the day I used to be really
happy going to Outback like Outback was
like a 10 out of 10 experience for him
but then as he got rich like now it's
like well going to Fleming's is 10 out
of 10 experience for me but even now
going to Fleming's is like you know like
a six out of ten because it's like a
regular day just like same thing like
when you sleep with a new girl like when
you first when you just have sex in
general like yes I had sex but then you
start having sex with a bunch of girls
like you know if you have sex like with
two or three girls a day and you're like
kind of used to it you're kind of like
well you know that was cool but you just
keep on like you have to keep on raising
the bar to keep on stimulating your
dopamine if you really want to get down
to it but then you become like this
dopamine slave that you're just like on
this endless hedonistic treadmill that
ultimately leads you nowhere and you
have no fulfillment and I personally
think because I just had this Revelation
recently I went home and I hung out with
my my brother my brother got married
when he was 20. he's now uh 31 and he
has three kids he's been married since
he was 20. he has three kids it was
hanging out with my nieces and nephews
and the house and everything was just so
chaotic and wild all the kids are
hugging my legs they're like Uncle John
Uncle John Uncle John and I was so happy
and I was so thrilled and just having
the time of my life and I was like oh my
God this is free yep like I'm not paying
any money for this and I was just like I
have all this money I have all this
expensive suits I have my fake teeth
I have everything you know and I'm just
like [__] I miss the real reality of
life I missed a meme which is family and
happiness
I have a question if you met um a real
virgin like not not the girl in the
couch
a real a real version to the point you
believed it and she said like I want to
wait till we're married to have sex
would you do it depends on how
attractive she was and because you're
just like a 200 pound virgin but yeah
she's she's cute let's say she's cute
honestly and she was like and I could
know there was no treachery in her and
she's down to make children yeah you
could I mean you wouldn't no for sure
but you you you have a gut feeling she's
telling the truth you're Discerning yeah
you're Discerning with yeah absolutely
oh wow I would do it how about you how
long would you date her before you I
mean I'm not trying I'm not gonna go two
years no sex so like what six months if
if everything's in line and like I meet
her parents and everything's good and
I'm like this [__] is not out for me
for my money yeah you know like I would
do it like I would do it like two months
three to six months I'd do it and that's
the thing it's like like I feel like if
younger women heard that like that's the
quickest way to get marriage from what
do you think about it what do you think
about the counter argument that people
sometimes bring all these shows though
because what if you did that and then
you're married to her and then somehow
the sex is no good or you're kind of
sexual would that matter to you listen
sex is like ice cream it's never really
bad it's just like you know it's pretty
good no matter what like I don't know
bad sex bad sex has to be like she's got
her legs locked up and she's like you
know just like me like pushing you away
like this is hurting too much like yeah
sorry uh corn Stars right I never
sexually incompatible
but you can become good at sex yeah
that's a lie it kind of becomes good and
that's what hoes say hoes like what if
the sex was bad like okay I know you're
oh because your entire value is based
upon sex don't even say that's mouth no
like like that's the thing like if you
look okay here's the thing uh when you
love a woman and and you're really in
tune with her and like mentally you're
connected you're like damn I [__]
love this woman somebody stormed in this
house I would kill everybody to like
defend her yeah right
missionary is enough
yeah missionaries I don't need her to
like jumping off me and throwing it back
and all that yeah actually if a woman
like that speaking about my ex when a
woman is like [__] that's another
thing she told me she wasn't that sexual
experience but she'd do some [__] I was
like
where did you learn that because this is
you you know as long as you do
consistently
like what
what was sex and it's long breaks in
between do you think that would be an
issue for you or do you think like or do
you think that wouldn't be an issue for
you for me personally like in my
relationships like if I need sex when I
want it
um I I know every feminist in the world
just this guy
out the window
[Laughter]
um no not as such I think I I kind of
agree with John actually I was kind of
being a plain Devil's Advocate there a
little bit because I think you're right
I think especially for guys I mean come
on the sex is always kind of good his
sex is always good so so I do I do take
your point I think if you seriously if I
suppose the only issue is if you're then
marrying her quite quickly in this
hypothetical situation would you know
would you have enough time to be able to
really evaluate if she is the right
person as a partner that's that's maybe
that's what Paul's saying like if you
know if you really knew and everything
was lined up you know what I mean but I
think that's it all to that question
personally I also think I also think as
well just just just just just
no just part that one second just just
to add to what John's said actually I
think actually it's kind of gonna be a
funny thing for me to say but I think
sex is actually overrated so what I
think of guys we place too much emphasis
oh yeah man sex blah blah blah Yes
actually like like because when you're
particularly when you're looking at a
long-term relationship yeah the Sexes
get a I don't say die off but it's it's
gonna diminish it
that for me that's the number one way
for me to spot a hoe is she's like when
she talks one of her leading points is
like sex or the quality of sex I'm like
oh you [__] you street walker you
know like even the other way around
God's gonna be like oh a guy that's
talking about how big this dick is his
dick clearly has to be small yeah yeah
I mean it's like when when people lead
with the insecurity we can spot the
insecurity right I really think that's
what it is but me personally I don't
think I would
um get like for marriage so Paul could
you repeat the question for me please
was it um like if would I get married
when was the ideal age for you to get
married no no it was the Virgin one um
would you wait till marriage yeah no the
reason the reason the reason the reason
why I wouldn't wait till marriage is
only because like I really think you
truly know a woman when you start
becoming sexual with her it's not to do
with the sex I think things get revealed
about their characteristic only because
like you see you have to understand sex
is a very vulnerable thing to do with
someone so there's certain
characteristics here certain ways that
she'll act towards you more confidently
after you two have sex maybe she can be
more confidently clingy with you like
like how many times as they you know
what's interesting I noticed these like
answers change with guys like kind of
right around the time they really want a
wife
no it's true nothing is there isn't it
could I have sex with other people what
oh oh so so she's like oh we can't have
sex but
when you when like when you have sex
with them it'd be interesting to ask you
see how do y'all
but I I think you know going back to
this because like I I agree with Troy
because you know we're I think all of us
on the panel are we get enough sex we're
like sex is overrated right guys
but I I think the number one thing is
this too like when you like and I know
like the red build community is like
anti-love but like when you actually
love a woman like it's really nothing
like it the sex is amazing it's just
icing on the cake because you already
love her yeah yeah you know sex doesn't
make you fall in love with a woman like
her personality her goodness like the
way she's good to you know like if she
makes the bed in the morning like like
she massages you stuff like that that's
what you would fall in love like you
know that's that's what makes you fall
in love like you know when you like I
was dating a girl one time and I went
hiking on a mountain and she's like I
got you these like feet things to like
put on your feet to like help you after
that I was like I will kill every man in
the world for you
you know yeah yeah you know what emotion
I think kills relationships when the
women get spiteful when it starts to be
about keeping score what do you mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what do you
mean exactly that's like you can almost
see women when they're older like in
their in their 40s and you can just tell
they've been keeping score for like 20
years that's like building up resentment
over Tit for Tat yeah yeah yeah you know
like when you're when you hang out with
your boys too like you know if you're
really good friends with your boys
you're like all right sit out I'm paying
like you know you're just fighting like
I'm paying I'm paying I'm paying but if
you're like with a friend he's like well
I paid last time so you gotta pay this
time like you listen here you cheap [__]
yeah that's the [__] out of here
[Laughter]
your boy's like listen I know you're
broke shut the [__] up I'm gonna pay
again
think these like 50 50 we have equal set
equal partnership relationships work
because no you're constantly keeping
score of who made the decision last time
or what time you like no listen all of
these it's supposed to be a default to
him no listen yeah
all of these like all these anti-red
build channels all these
anti-conservative channels all these
libtards all these people trying to talk
[__] about saying that their way of
doing things is disappear here we've
been doing it that way and everybody is
[__] miserable you walking in the
streets people are not happy in today's
modern times women's misery index is the
highest it's ever been in America they
are not happy so when they're trying to
say like oh we gotta like we've read
this study that was funded by these
people from John Hopkins University and
they said that we should do it this this
this this way it's like yeah well we've
been doing that and there's like a
million women crying on Tick Tock about
how miserable they are and how single
they are I don't want to see independent
you know many videos have you seen of
that recently yeah it's so beautiful I
love it I love it so much no like the
way that things are going right now are
that's why people like Andrew Tate are
celebrating he's literally the most
Googled man in the world because he's
pretty he's preaching Traditional Values
you know we've we've given this like new
age order their chance and they have
completely failed everyone well and I
had like a red pill moment the other day
where I realized like most people have
never seen a real traditional
relationship yeah because behind the
scenes the moms usually run the show and
you can look at that and consumer buying
decisions like men are supposed to make
the financial decisions in a household
that's traditional 80 women make 80 of
consumer buying decisions most people
have not seen it most people's mothers
will not say okay if the father makes a
decision she disagrees with and a lot of
times there's like a whole generation of
dads that are just trying to make their
wives happy yep I have a curious
question for you is that anything
agitate has said that you've seen that
you disagree with me uh this question to
everyone actually I don't question
everyone but it was many yeah the first
time I didn't I saw him I didn't like
him because he had a he had a cheating
party
um
so the first time I reacted to it I was
like I was like I think I probably it's
like I think I insulted him or something
I don't remember what I said because I
was just like what is this attention
seeking got like why would you do why
would you bring all the girls you're
dating put them in it
and he was like oh they're crying and I
was like that's cold that's icy yeah I
think the whole pushing for like you
know multiple women like when you when
you're an average guy and you make like
sixty thousand dollars a year and you
like have a regular you know middle
class job and you're like listen [__]
I'm about to go get another hoe like
that's just not realistic so I don't
think that's good advice because when
you give advice you want to give advice
that is good for the majority of people
yeah now could some men pull that off I
mean yeah they could but the majority
people will fail and then your message
is perpetuating a life of misery for
average people so I def I I just think
that that needs to stop like I think
these guys saying like oh well you know
I have multiple women and this and that
like
I think this is terrible advice like you
guys like one is enough and like the
reality is this too like Tate had
multiple women right and he's in [__]
Romanian prison to this day like even
though it's false like he or there's no
real evidence he's not been really
officially locked down he's he's in
prison because of that [__] or he's you
know he's on house arrest and dealing
and and like in literally the worst time
of his entire life based upon his own
advice so I just think that's one thing
I wholeheartedly disagree with I do
think the me too allegation could happen
from a wife too though yeah I don't
think you necessarily just because with
the divorce documentary there's so many
guys where it was their wife that did it
to him yo yeah it just kind of transfers
the power you know um you could argue
it's more likely though with I think the
main thing that like I want to say this
is a disagreement I think it was just
like a realization when I clocked it
like I say when he first came out yeah
and the way he'd explain his points yeah
it would be with like a um with a level
of tenacity in it and obviously first
looking in I could be like oh that's a
bit harsh but then I think I've probably
seen him say it or something like that
of him say yo I'm playing a character to
some type of to some degree to gain a
certain amount of attention and it was
working and I think the second that he
said that I think that's when I like I
actually truly like rated the guy only
because it's because he set a goal and
he got the result and the foundations of
the points aren't destructive against
what I believe in so like let's say okay
be strong okay cool be like you know
make sure you saw financially stable
okay cool keep yourself mentally
depression doesn't exist obviously I can
see how that can be controlled special
but keep yourself mentally good like
because the foundations here are like
you know very like aligned with how I am
as person yeah it's that's what makes me
agree but then let's say that flipping I
don't know let's say you've heard of the
music guy for example
yeah I know I interviewed him he's
probably gonna come back tomorrow for a
show actually or even even with that for
example like let's say that okay him
he's someone that's blown up in his bank
account but let's say that he's he's
saying yeah kids need to jump into yards
and stuff like I couldn't agree with the
foundation of the point like even if
he's coming with the same tenacity as
Andrew the foundation of his point lie
in a negative direction towards what I
believe in but in something like what
Andrew takes is more positive towards
what I believe in so I really focus on
the foundation of the point you're
making not how you're saying it yeah
we're gonna I'm gonna Read Super chats
different
um okay I don't think sparkling water is
necessarily going yeah
it's not what it's nice
I'd say sorry just quit I said the only
thing I not permanently the main thing I
disagreed when he said that oh as a
father he would go away for two weeks
and then come back personally for me I'd
rather have a strong presence
I agree with kid on that as well like
you can't just be like a pop in and out
Dad yeah
I might disagree just slightly on this
one I'm not sure it's an interesting one
but that is sort of at the heart of
because what I like what I like one of
the things I liked about the toys is
they're quite sort of they're very much
about going out Forge your own path and
not getting tied down in the normal
Domesticity that people get tied into
but they're sort of the weight their
work around as far as having kids is
concerned is well the father is there
and he's the supportive but he doesn't
need to be there the whole time
agree with that but a father being
present is like
they have like they have a study that if
a father is just present in a household
not if he doesn't even talk if he
doesn't even communicate but if a father
is just present anxiety goes down
depression goes down the probability of
her being a hoe goes down yeah this did
like not even being involved but the
fact that the father is just there so I
can't I can't agree with like the soul
like you know just [__] off and you know
be pumping be like a dad you know you
know what's interesting I actually was
like sort of that kid because my dad um
he would go to India for like two weeks
at a time yeah
um and so I think what you have to think
about is you really can't have
everything yeah you can so what you know
what I realized is that you know my dad
was doing that because he loved us and
now I I can spend all the time I want
with my dad because he was able to work
so hard when we were younger and now
he's retired where a lot of my friends
dads are still
was it every month he was gone for half
the month
um I don't remember to be honest like
are you telling the truth
I I for a period of time I know he was
gone a lot
um so I I don't know how long that you
know your childhood's kind of blurry
like yeah yeah I think I don't remember
how long but but you know because I I
used to think about that would I rather
had him like around more and I just was
like you know I don't have college debt
I can spend all the time I want with my
dad now which there's way more time in
the future than the past like I don't
know I think I see where they're coming
from where like if you have to go build
something yeah like your family will be
okay if you have to I definitely see
where they're coming from because
because what do you think about it if
you go back a few Generations the father
was actually even if I look at my own
family like my grandfather quite quite a
remote sort of figure yeah they weren't
as like caring and sharing and nurturing
as far as sort of encouraged to be today
so if you look about and look like back
to Victorian times the father was
actually quite remote from the family
and often in upper class families you
know the kid would just get sent off to
boarding school anyway now you could
argue well you know what was the
psychological outcome or the kids of
that but that seemed to work pretty well
for building the empire
almost like person I know and the day
that I realized that everything that he
did was for us that was the day like we
had the best relationship yeah because
every everything my dad built was for us
he he just wanted us to not have to pay
for college because he spent like most
of his 20s in debt from all this college
debt from a degree he didn't even get
yeah and yeah and all he like wanted was
like I remember one day when I was like
younger
um I was like bitching about my dad to
my mom I was like I was like Mom like
like Dad this dad like I was just being
a teenager right you know well I was I
didn't always speak this highly you know
people are stupid teenagers yeah and she
just and she just like looked at me and
she's like do you know what he did for
you today and she's like he did this he
took your bags out of the car he drove
an hour and a half to come see you play
your volleyball game this this this this
this this she paid for this this and
I've never been so humbled in my life I
was just like
but I just think it's like important
that you teach the kids like that
mindset that's like everything they're
doing is for you oh yeah and and for the
record I I think for me I wouldn't say
that oh I'd have I would be there 24 7
and I've even had this conversation like
I was saying oh would you be okay if I
was there for like three days a week and
then had my own place for like four days
a week but I did see a clip or when
Andrew take to talk about his dad would
be gone for like two three months at a
time yeah I think for me two three
months is a bit much like ideally at
least 22 months yeah that's what that is
yeah that's what I'm saying yeah that's
a lot it's all extreme I think that I'd
want a stronger presence
what kid is saying that's actually
healthy for the relationship like you do
need a degree of separation in your
relationships because when you're
constantly on top of each other you're
gonna like I don't [__] want to kill
this [__] like you know you just like
you're when you're on top of each other
you have no room to separate and
appreciate you've got to give your girl
an opportunity to miss you but you know
you know what I mean you know like I
think my standpoint is like a bit of a
different perspective perspective to
what everyone said as well is because my
parents like on are separate like they
like I grew up not seeing my parents hug
or kiss like if I'm being honest with
you yes if I saw my mom and dad kiss
each other right now that would be weird
to me because I've not grown up with
that psychologically being normal to me
because I haven't seen that so I'm used
to the ideology of me just being at my
mom's then me going to my dad's when I
need to go see my dad let me come back
to Mama and see my mom and because of
that that that that
um that's that separative element that I
grew up with it's also not necessarily
affect my okay it's it's probably
affecting me for relationships where I'm
saying when I grow up I don't want that
for my kids where I do wanna I do want
them to be able to see what their
parents are like together but at the
same time yeah I'm also looking at the
impact he had on me whilst I was growing
I feel yeah that even though them two
were separate my dad was a very present
father yeah I'd only have to see him
once every three weeks but it's in the
in that few seconds of seeing him yeah
it would be my whole like that's all I
needed to know like like just go to the
park a bit kicking the ball a bit going
for a bike ride that little thing here
I'll take that memory over my mom
shouting at me in the morning to clean
up something 20 times yeah and it'll be
the same level because it's like it's
not to me say that I love my dad more
than my mom it's just that like as the
father is pretty impactful on the child
and and especially when you're a male
and father is going to help solve your
problems in a way that women just like
yeah
and we get like stressed yeah and so
when you like when we have all these
prop like you bring your mom a problem
it's like there's stress to it but it's
like dads are so focused on like fixing
the problem and like I I see why like
stoicism is so needed in society because
we just cannot do what men do we are not
the same and we keep painting to women
that we can be the same and we are just
not
um
[Music]
yeah sorry what you're saying um is kind
of in line with what Tate snake isn't it
because because Tate was saying you know
his father was away for a month
but his father was also such a strong
presence in his life and they still talk
it wasn't there if my father wasn't
there we wouldn't have the release [__]
that we have now you could you could
argue I mean obviously tight is The
Situation he's in now but he became the
most Google man in the world yeah so the
fact that his father wasn't there the
whole time he still got on to be like
yeah yeah you know so there's there's I
could see arguments on both sides also
as well I do find that for example I
have a friend that's in a relationship
right now in it and obviously I know
what life was like when me and him were
both single I mean who evolved as men
just insane he just gone through
University just being men in it and I
also seen the changes in him when he
when he became a father and he settled
down in a relationship and did don't get
it twisted his relationship is his
happiness it's his pride it's his family
he loves his family so forth but there
was an element year of and this is just
pure honesty for my side you know that
inner animal that inner drive that that
thing that that kick there was an
element of that lowering like for
example he loved music now he's not
doing he doesn't want he can't be about
to do sorry this was your friends this
is my this is my friend I let him know
my friend he's a male he's a male friend
of mine oh he's in a relationship he's
in a relationship and he has a child and
the thing is that like the relationship
he loves the relationship I'm not saying
that anything's wrong with that element
however yeah I know I know what he
looked like when he was just on his own
and that drive that I saw in him to just
do yeah to just do regular tasks when he
got into a relationship here he was less
more he was less he was less motivated
yeah like when I was speaking to him he
was less oh yeah oh the babies crying
all day like I don't know how Megan I
don't have my girlfriend those who all
day she's struck she's strong for that
like me oh that's babies and it's like
it's not to say now don't get this year
he he loves that child and he loves that
woman that is his family but that
element has decreased because of that
relationship to some degree what's your
opinion you're gonna say somebody's
going to drop the testosterone thing
yeah so your testosterone drops when
you're in a relationship but
particularly when you're in a domestic
relationship you know it's funny though
the one thing that stops your
testosterone from dropping in those
relationships go on to your team do you
know do you guys know what is it trying
to cheat on your girl I'm not involved
oh my God
scientists I'm just a scientist Savage
Savage yeah I guess you're still out
there but yeah statistically speaking
your testosterone does drop especially
when you have children so what does that
mean so how do you like translate that
information you had to cheat
[Laughter]
I gotta I gotta Read Super chats though
um okay Lawrence Bullock do you guys
find it ironic that a majority of women
want to get married but don't understand
what it means to be wives or want to be
a wife
um no trust to women I was worried for
10 years she cheated on the beginning in
the beginning she cheated on me the
beginning of year 11. she was a virgin
when we got married no matter what you
do you can't read others mind an Intent
no point in getting married anymore
Lawrence I'm just now noticing how
common rational the panel is compared to
your usual panels no cattiness is
refreshing probably because it's all
male
uh Wayne Uh politicians in Romania get
caught up in the metoo movement and have
had to show they took allegations
seriously Andrew was an easy target but
he never sees the return of a lot of his
property good luck in the on the Move in
the new studio
um Let me refresh it really quick I
think that's all of them
um also guys like the video I think
there's over a thousand there's like 1
500 people in here so let's try to get
to 2 000 likes um because we're at 1.4
right now
um but I think actually we're gonna
close out the show yeah it's a bit late
so
um final thoughts you know starting with
you MLD
uh
I feel personally attacked by the
non-virgin girl
you want some therapy for your trauma I
need it I need it we could do a therapy
episode tomorrow I'm actually I'm gonna
cry and walk off
um no I just think instead of you
insulted her teeth oh and her outfit
like everyone would say
there was plenty of criteria to insult
but no I mean ultimately it just you
know it just lets me know that my
message is pure the more women I make
Angry the more I know I'm like on the
right path
um because it was just funny because I
wasn't even like trying to poke at her
or do anything I was just like ramp stop
the cap because like they do the fresh
fit you know it was just funny so um but
I mean final thoughts you know I think
that going back to the main thing we're
talking about later date and his uh live
stream today I think that ultimately
Andrew Tate a lot of people hate on him
because he has the hearts of young men
and he is motivating there has never
been
a more monumentally positive
influence for young men in today's time
then entertain honestly like who is the
last one like literally with Hulk Hogan
I don't know like Donald Trump like
maybe don I think Donald Trump's in
close second right The Establishment
came for him and even if some people
would argue Donald Trump wasn't right
well I say getting to the younger
generation though I think no one's doing
it like Andrew no no that's what I'm
trying to say like and I think that's
why they're after him because the case
is [__] and you know he's just been
poor man him and his family and his
children have been dragged into the mud
so I think ultimately for you viewers at
home just sit down quietly and
rationally think for a second do you
really think they're after him because
he's a human trafficker like if you have
as much clout much money you're a good
looking guy four-time kickboxing world
champion why would you be like hey you
know what I'm 35 I'm 34.
you want to get together and traffic
some women Tristan
like how does it even logically make
sense right so I think that
um viewers at home you just need to sit
down and confidently think about this
and um it's always been it's always a
great show thank you so much for having
me Pearl great to reunite with Troy on
on today's show as well you know that's
all I got to say follow me on Instagram
hot dude life follow me on uh YouTube
which is Modern Life dating and then I'm
I'm launching the inner game healing
Summit the endure so go to
intergamehealing.com get on the waiting
list for that and we're going to help
you guys endure through all the mental
things you're going through I forgot to
make that the topic today tomorrow
tomorrow we're going to talk about what
can you endure in a relationship let's
do it could you endure cheating what's
going to endure abuse that's it what
could you endure bring as many women as
you can
I'll tell them the topic too
so yeah I think final thoughts are
regarding the angiotite thing
is a master of rhetoric and he is a
master of presenting a narrative and
framing a narrative and I think really
in the whole age of social media and
influences and and such like we haven't
seen anybody of his ilk and I think just
watching the way that he's conducting
himself through this and the way that he
is taking what's being thrown at him and
then reshaping it and putting very
across his point of view in a very
forcible way is a master class and I
think that that's something that you
know we can all learn from really I
think it's incredible the way that he
almost single-handedly well with Tristan
by his side of course but has taken on
the mainstream media and he's actually
propagating his own version of what's
Happening Here in a way that is
incredibly impactful yeah and he's
actually winning more hearts and Minds
arguably than the mainstream view of
things I mean if you look at how many
people are on that that live stream that
they did well it's 500 000 500 000. just
just incredible 95 of comments are
positive as well yeah so yeah so you
know it's it's just just watching the
the master at work here I think is
incredibly
well it's it's something to behold put
it that way I think it's a it's a it's
it's an historic thing that we're seeing
um anyway so just follow me on YouTube
at real Troy Francis Instagram realtro
Francis Twitter at real try Francis as
well and thanks Paul ever so much for
having me on as always and um great to
see Mr MLD back in the house
um final thoughts on uh Andrew Tate
um no one is perfect no one is perfect
um it's a shame that we live in a time
where even if you have a different
perspective to someone then you have to
completely disown and discard them
um while there are some things I may not
agree on the core of what he says I
completely agree on the principles you
can see he's a very principled and moral
man and I think he is an excellent
example of what men need to become to
help the people around them today
um so I think you know whether you agree
with him fully or not I think if you're
somebody who couldn't take something
away from him
um I think you'd be lost
um but as always thank you for having me
Paul
um thank you for having me good to see
meet John Troy and these guys uh you can
follow me at stasic with kit that is on
YouTube Instagram and Tick Tock and I'll
see you next time
so I'd say final thoughts I do honestly
believe and me being the youngest one on
the podcast like I know my generation
lacks a lot of responsibility I know
that my my generation is becoming a lot
more emotional and I think that we need
to go we need to do 180 turn on that and
go completely against that right now I
think men need to focus on trying to
become the strongest version of
themselves just like what we've talked
about today mentally staying on top of
everything and it's like just being the
best version of yourself because right
now it is a war going on whether you
thought you were part of it or not isn't
important there is a war going on for
everyone which is going to affect
everyone and if you're not in the right
mental space and you're not like strong
enough for yourself you only do bad
things towards the people around you so
I'd say right now I'd say everyone just
focus on being the best version of
himself and yeah my name is follow me on
Instagram smad uh Follow Me music sdmi
then also my um directing company Apollo
Vision on Instagram
yeah that's it
uh there's one more Super Chat Edgar
mld's favorite Pokemon
move move a move is indoor endure
um all right guys um a couple
announcements before we end the show um
sign up for our Google form I I know
I've been gaslighting you guys about
meetups I have I did have one troy as my
witness
I did have one it was fun right it was
great yeah until we got kicked out yeah
yeah yeah
the website the closing time was
different but we're um we're probably
gonna do one in the next like two weeks
in England so sign up for our Google
form like the video on your way out um
can you make sure that's in the chat um
can you pin that as a comment King the
Google form
just at the end of the show we will do
it okay like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time hey
I